and the governor's emergency order
number 12 first went to executive order
2024 this public body is authorized to
meet electronics
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if invited participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91a
anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by role culver
we'll start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know
alone
representative grace
president at home my wife is in the
house
representative
my wife is in the other room
representative grota
not yeti
i'll repeat those representatives
in the committee room representative
mcguire
president in the committee room
representative o'brien
representative pearson
representative roy
president
saint george island florida alone
representative santo nestaso
uh here in tinsel alone
representative schmidt
i am president of my home office in
dover i am alone
representative
i am present at my home in pembroke
alone
representative schultz
good morning i'm present in concord at
my home and my husband gene taylor will
be in and out of the room
okay uh the clerk is president of the
room representative jacob
let me repeat some names
representative
yes
where are you please yes home and family
throughout the house
uh representative o'brien
i am president i am uh
home in nashua alone
representative pearson
may i ask uh these three people not
president or
judy and pearson if anybody notices
i'm sorry
yakovich thank you
if anybody notices their arrival please
let me know if i don't notice it
uh we are assured those uh four people
okay
and
open the hearing on
senate bill 104 and i call senator
reagan the crime sponsor
good morning members of
house edna and
i'm happy to bring before you today
senate bill 104 fna
and this is an act that adopts um
omnibus legislation and relate relative
to the classification of state employee
positions
and reverse auctions
and
um did you explain part one to us since
i believe that's your section
yes
so
as the chairman of the joint committee
unemployed classification it falls to me
to present the legislation
that then codifies
the actions we've taken and
recommendations
that we've sent on to the
fiscal committee and
there are
health and human services is still in
the process of reclassifying all their
management positions so they'll be a
constant barrage of classification
changes
from the department
so that's what i bring to you here today
are there any questions from the
committee
representative if you'd
introduce yourself and
say where you are
yes um i'm representative jackie grota
i'm here in my home office alone
thank you
any other any any questions for senator
reagan representative
fellows thank you madam chair um senator
reagan
these these are all being
deleted well not women um so the top
ones are being deleted
so
no the health and human services and no
other state agencies
will have this classification or they or
they may have the um
well just that that's the question so so
health and human services and no other
agencies currently have
these jobs
or do they just not have these jobs at
these levels
pay grade
through department of administrative
services all agencies are
subject to having requests made from
jcec to change their job
classifications and pay levels um
it's just that the the bulk of changes
that we're seeing now
as a carryover from years before
is that health and human services
so this doesn't exclude anybody and it
doesn't automatically include anybody
uh thank you
uh senator i have a question
yes i noticed that you're changing the
chair of the
jcec to biennial which makes perfect
sense
and you're also stretching
the
reviews hhs's reviews of their
management structure from four years to
seven years
uh
could you explain that
the
i think the commissioner myers at the
time thought that the that
reclassification would go a lot faster
than it has been going
and uh
they just wanted this cushion
because it involves 80 some positions
that are being reclassified
and
it was a constant source of confusion on
jcec um
representative schmidt and i have served
for
more than 14 years on the
on this committee and it is
it's always awkward and
and we couldn't never figure out why
they went to a one-year rotation and not
for the session
so it just made sense like you said
madam chair
okay
representative you have a question
you're muted
thank you
is is the only way to do this through
legislation because if we
or is there another it is okay thank you
yes these positions are in statute
and therefore that we have to have
legislation to change the statute
thank you
madam chair yes representative schmidt
so if i'm as uh senator reagan has
alluded to me i could add just a couple
of words for one thing the jcec does not
meet on a regular basis it meets as
needed with regard to positions that are
being
added
or
promoted or changed in some cash
the jcec is the
uh with regards to that
that is the function of the edna
committee that's why senator reagan is
here today with this bill
subsequently to our action in edna
the finance committee will then take up
any financial aspects of any decision
that the jc ec has made
but because we don't meet regularly or
we only meet at the call of the chair so
to speak
to the degree that we're not meeting at
the time that the
session changes from one year to the
next it's very
awkward and unwieldy and that's why that
aspect is being changed
thank you
other questions for senator reagan
all right seeing none thank you senator
and
i will be presenting the amendment that
you approved
from commissioner arlinghaus later
after we finished with the bill
thank you
senator carson
good morning madam chair and good
morning uh committee members um for the
record my name is sharon carson and i
represent senate district 14 comprising
the towns of londonderry hudson and
auburn and i have part two
of this omnibus bill this morning for
your consideration which deals with
reverse auctions and this was a request
of the department of administrative
services
briefly
reverse auctions are an electronic
bidding process in which bidders make
offers to supply commodities or services
to the state at increasingly lower
prices
they are a live event where suppliers
compete in open forum to offer their
best possible prices
reverse auctions are currently being
used as a tool to apply downward
pressure on suppliers in conjunction
with the public bidding process
traditional electronic reverse auctions
have a track record of success in our
state counterparts including mass
vermont connecticut and rhode island and
have proven to facilitate securing
substantially lower prices than a
traditional procurement approach
the difference between new hampshire and
other states is that reversed auctions
are currently performed as part of the
rfp process in advance of any public
bid opening
this legislation should ideally create a
future state which prohibits the release
of specific vendors pricing information
prior to the conclusion of a reverse
option thereby maximizing cost
reductions
adoption of this legislation would
streamlight the state's reverse bidding
process and potentially
significantly reduce prices paid by the
department of administrative services
for goods and services
madam chair i have received some
language for a potential amendment
and it goes on to say that there's one
comment addressed at the time of our
submission of a fiscal note worksheet on
this matters
um reverse auction raised technical
questions relating to the application of
the provision of rsa 91a
and rsa 21g colon 37 which is disclosure
of financial information regarding
requests for bids and requests for
proposal
and it says in order to address those
concerns they believe that the uh
language that they'd like to present in
the following paragraph should be added
to the bill um that
amendment madam chair is in the process
of being
written up by ols and i will get it to
you just as soon as it is available so
it will be made available to your
committee um hopefully
because this was a request of the
department um they're going to have
individuals here to discuss this in
greater detail more than i could
and they will be able to uh maybe
address the amendment itself so at this
point madam chair i will conclude my
testimony thank you thank you senator uh
i
don't recognize the names of the
attendees so if someone is here from the
department would you please raise your
hand so i can recognize you
okay
mr lunetta when you can uh
when you can please mute yourself and
speak
good morning everybody
i'm here with uh
our leadership commissioner olinghouse
deputy commissioner
keane
and administrator uh
for policies and guidelines tom care
and the purpose of the reverse auctions
we've had some successes and we've
collaborated with some other states
uh recently concluding
a joint venture with the state of
vermont with regard to road salt and we
achieved significant cost savings
in summary in essence what it allows us
to do
is provide perform a
best and final live bidding
process electronically whereby the
bidders do not see who they're bidding
against they're just a number as the
price bids continue to go go lower
and more competitive it just makes for a
very effective conclusion
okay thank you are there any questions
from the committee about the rehearsal
representative
thank you
so i'm familiar with reverse auctions
from my previous um position my
professional experience my professional
excuse me represent could you
get closer to the microphone or
something you're speaking more loudly
i'll increase my volume is that better
all right i'll uh
i wanted to know along with um
goods like hard goods do you uh
anticipate that the department with
departments might be it might need this
for services
uh we're looking into
services that would
work
so the answer is yes the short answer is
yes uh the the volume of services that
we'll be able to run through
will be i would say on a limited more
limited basis than obviously commodities
follow up please follow up so when you
enter these um requests are there
specifications that go along with it
whether they be products or services
yes correct
okay thank you
fellows thank you madam chair
um
i'm wondering if you can tell me how
this affects
the rfp process because i know that the
current process
at least some of the time um depends
what the what you're looking for would
have a bidder's conference and answer
questions and
um that sort of thing all right
so
the rfb process the only difference with
passing in this bill will will the
difference will be
the bids will not be disclosed until the
conclusion of the
actual reverse auction
uh the way the laws
we have we have to re we have to receive
the bids through a public opening
and that price point sets the bar
for the beginning and commencement of
the subsequent reverse auction this will
just close the loop
and it nothing will be released until
we we complete the actual
process
so follow-up
well
follow up please
um thank you so if i if i understand
what you're saying um suppose if you
were looking for a reverse auction for
paving the highway something like that
then
you would still issue the rfp
and there would still be an opportunity
for anybody to ask questions about clear
and clarifications is that correct and
and then the next step would be that
they would submit their bids but
is that is that how it goes
yes the irb would be issued we'd have a
question and answer period
defined for any clarification
and the process really would remain
unchanged the only difference would be
upon uh submission and receipt of the
proposals or quotes
nothing would be released until the
conclusion of the process of research
okay thank you that that clarifies what
i was uh asking about thank you
you're welcome
representative
has joined us if you'd uh
stay where you are
at home alone in the room
while we have yesterday
we have a question please
you said nothing is revealed until the
uh
reverse auction is completed exactly
what is revealed upon completion of the
oak process
so the contract the resulting contract
and the price point would be disclosed
publicly
as it is today only would be at the
conclusion of the auction
thank you only the winner and the
the winning bid and the vendor is
identified all the rest of this uh
other bids uh
are nothing's discussed except that
is that correct
that would be correct assuming the
amendment has passed
thank you thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair while we have
arlington
i might just add that he is the other
key ingredient in the jce uh in this
case commissioner arlinghaus they manage
and coordinate all the incoming requests
from departments
uh
to employee class to employ the rankings
and so forth so he is the other key
player
and
he is the one that
informs
the chair
of the process
uh of the and that's when the the
jcec will meet it's not on a regular
basis at all thank you representative
broda you have a question
thank you madam chair i are the um
are there bids that enter through this
reverse auction are they from approved
suppliers
do you have a list of of approved
suppliers or can are they the ones that
that enter in this reverse auction
or can anyone
they have to be a registered veteran
with the state of new hampshire they all
are pre-qualified thank you
you're welcome
thank you other questions representative
fellows
thank you madam chair i'm just wondering
is is there still is there something in
the process
that would um let you exclude a low
bidder if these people have done jobs
for the state before and and you think
they didn't really do a very good job
so before it goes to our reverse auction
contract uh service provider we our team
in procurement does an analysis both a
technical and commercial review so our
process really doesn't change
uh prior to it going to the to the
reverse auction end
so yes the answer is yes we would stop
anybody that is
uh on a department list or if they
perform
poorly or if they're not technically
compliant to the specifications
thank you
you're welcome and de roy you have a
question
i do thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
is there uh
situations where you would not take the
lowest bidder
and
[Music]
how do you deal with keeping them to
that low bid in other words cost
overruns
thank you
um so if there were a technical reason
for that to happen we probably would not
have them participate in the actual
live auction
process we catch that up front
and it have to be a specific
reason of validation not to
pursue that
uh avenue so i'm not sure i answered
your question but we would have a
process
to stop that
let me let me give that a little bit of
a shot this is um charlie arlinghaus i'm
the commissioner of the department
um
technically
while there it is possible to not accept
a low bidder if you if you find
something wrong with the low bidder you
would realistically have to find
something wrong with the low bidder the
the the state's competitive bidding
statutes are designed as much as
possible to eliminate judgment
from it what what the what policymakers
have decided over over many years since
um
since a predecessor of mine went to jail
in the 1940s over bidding um
one they've decided that it's very
important that there be a process that
is as open as possible
so if somebody wins the bid
and there's a manager who goes geez you
know i didn't i don't like that i mean i
we were really hoping to use home depot
or
that's a bad example but you know what i
mean um
we have to be very skeptical of that you
you can't want to use somebody because
you're comfortable so somebody is a low
bid and is going to be disqualified um
you have to be very careful that that
company that ends up getting
disqualified would have us would have a
strong ability to sue
so it doesn't happen very much typically
what would happen is they would not
reach the point where they were able to
bid
for example on construction contracts um
uh with the department division of
public works um there's a there's a
pre-qualified list
occasionally people uh people are banned
from bidding or there's a card in their
file so they don't they can't bid on
state work but once they qualify to bid
you're generally saying that we accept
you unless for some reason
you figured out they they they couldn't
bid or there was a problem
there are some rfps
uh proposals
um where there's a technical component
to them as well as a financial component
and so um there are occasions typically
i know this is true with us on
on a bunch of our large contracts
um
the low financial bidder is the one who
likely wins and the technical elements
are close but there is the possibility
that somebody is technically very very
weak
um and their pricing point is a little
bit higher and those those contracts are
awarded um
essentially on a point system where
finances are one component of technical
qualifications are another but we have
to be very very careful the mandate for
us in the competitive bidding process
is to um is to be as as dispassionate
and as neutral as as possible
and if i may just add to that conclusion
uh that's why a lot of services won't
really apply for this platform
opportunity that's really primarily
geared to i say widgets commodities that
are vanilla
uh and easy to
meet a specification and really that it
does become complying with the rsas
which is low price prevails
thank you follow up follow up please
please
thank you again for taking my question
um i guess the second part of my
question with regards to cost overruns
ties into the low bidder thing is
if someone is uh
under bidding
what they should do just to get the
award
are they prevented then from uh
building the state from war because of
cost overruns because they under bid
just to get the contract
it's a it's a great question and it's
something that comes up in uh
particularly in construction contracts
both ones we administer
um and obviously dot ones um this came
up with the governor and council a while
ago
um there's a contracting process they
would be held to a contract
and the contract is uh we have very good
contracts in the state um from the state
perspective from the contractor
perspective they might not agree um
because their hands are very much tied
every contract of that nature naturally
has a change order process because
things do change and you find unknown
conditions etc but change orders are
things that have to be agreed to by both
sides and they're done very carefully
and judiciously
if somebody is a particularly low bid
so on think of a large construction
contract where we we produce an estimate
and let's just say for the sake of
argument there were four bits and they
were 3.6 3.5 3.4 million
and then somebody been 2.1
before as part of the contracting
process before you would contract with
the person who was
remarkably low and surprisingly low
that's obviously a piece of information
you hear in your head and you think
oh did they miss something did they did
they see page 12 you know that kind of
thing
and you would have a conversation with
them and say you understand what you're
getting into
you understand the same process which is
a little bit cumbersome uh compared to a
lot of what you're used to and we have a
discussion with them
um occasionally what will happen is
there'll be somebody who says no i get
it i understand this we just say work
all the time i get what i'm doing
um and uh i got a good deal on paint
and uh and i'm gonna use it on the
process so we're good um but there's a
discussion occasionally somebody will
say oh i didn't realize that and and we
would explain to them
change orders are gonna be very hard to
come by just so you know
and so they know what they're getting
into so typically
someone like that might in the end walk
away doesn't happen much just because
the process of getting to be a bitter on
state work
is um is difficult in and of itself
but
part of that process is solved by
conversations and part of it is by
holding people to a contract where
you know they've been low and
we've had vendors who say
i didn't realize how low i was bidding
and i'm losing money and if i'm honest
our answer is typically um
i'm sorry about that but we do have a
contract
thank you
all right
representative schuett
thank you madam chair my question was
answered in the course of
previous conversation excellence
representative fellows then
thank you madam chair um i have a
question about
the decision whether or not to use the
reverse auction so how will you make
that decision and if a potential bidder
doesn't like your decision do they have
any um option to appeal that decision
so we do a pre-canvas we do market
analysis our team here at state as well
as our contract service provider
they do an independent study they
analyze what the conditions of the
market are what the price trends are we
already share our budget based on our
incumbent uh
live contracts that will be expiring
and a decision is made is it a go or no
go if it's a no-go meaning that we don't
think the reverse
auction would be beneficial to either
party whether it be the state and or
uh the the service provider we would
still do our conventional competitive
bid process whereby we would still issue
a formal rfp
and receive analyze and award a contract
outside of the reverse auction file
so is there any appeal process if they
didn't like it also our rfb goes out
with a disclaimer with a statement in
there that says state reserves as its
sole option to exercise
going into
a reverse auction so it's uh it's our
decision downstream after the bids
committee oh okay that that answers my
question thanks
representative
thank you
will there be a
um
i don't know what else what what other
word to use right well will there be a
review or an analysis done after we've
used this process
you know maybe after a year to see
indeed if
this was beneficial
so i i would call that a post-mortem
right so after a certain period of time
we look we look to see
i'm i have experience with reverse
auctions from my previous employment
um and there were good and bad things
that happened as a result of that
um so and i was we were a supplier in
the in the in the position
so
it can be very beneficial for the state
and for the supplier but it could also
be detrimental to both
and with that in mind what expectation
do you have any expectations
of a downside to this and what would
what might that be and how are you going
to prevent that from happening
so uh
first part of your question yes we are
tracking we will have metrics on a
case-by-case basis
uh we've done a couple as i mentioned
road salt we did with vermont uh the
result of that was we recognized about a
six percent savings vermont recognized
about a thirty six percent say we saved
four million dollars
uh we were about a half a million um
and
we'll track it the vendors
performed this past winter uh we got
good feedback on it and to me it was a
win for the states as well as uh the
vendors that participated throughout the
regions of both states
we will we will our partnerships are
very important to us
i think that's why we do such due
diligence up front
with respect to the pre-qualification
and determining
uh is it a viable way to go or should we
do it our conventional standard
competitive
paper process so we always have the
option
and we take that very seriously so yes
we will monitor it and provide reporting
thank you are there other questions on
reverse auctions
in that case
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
on
senate bill 104.
madam chair
yes representative
yes uh i was just curious uh on part one
if there's anyone present from
health and human services who cared to
testify on those positions
uh
if there is please raise your hand if
not uh
commissioner arlinghaus would you be
able to answer your question
probably
um i didn't actually
i didn't actually have a hand
okay i didn't actually have a question
it just seemed
serious with so many of that
department's
positions involved that no one was here
to speak to us
from that specific department
i think i can actually explain that if
it would help um
the process is is fairly standardized
and has been sort of ongoing with jcdc
over some time
um hhs has the most unclassified
positions in the state in part because
of a reorganization done 25 years ago
where they created a
senior executive service the so-called
terry morton positions
um and
it's a very recent thing where where
that committee
was insistent on uh jcec
insisted in a good way on on getting
them to re-evaluate all the positions
the positions all the unclassified
positions in the state were evaluated in
2001 when we created the new grid
unclassified grid classified grid um and
they're in the process of adjusting them
where um over time they've reached the
point where the working title for our
position
and the actual title for position were
radically divergent from each other
and this is a this is a significant
cleanup process and so
it it looks remarkable to this committee
when they look at the piece of
legislation
but i think for the
for the joint committee itself um it's a
it's something that's happening and they
understand it and they're and they're
prepared for it so so i think you know
hhs would not look at it you know i'm
here to talk about the amendment that
we're seeking um because it's it's
different
and i think hhs is probably not here to
talk about it because they think it's
um standard order of business if that
makes any sense
yes representative schuett you may
remember that we get a bill from the
jcec
pretty much every year
and the departments involved are almost
never there to speak on the positions
it's only the jcec that's there to
testify
thank you i thank you commissioner i
appreciate that explanation
okay representative schmidt
thank you man chair so uh commissioner
uh you may be aware of although it was
done under one of your predecessors
there was a study commission uh uh
chaired by senator carson who just left
the meeting so
i was hoping she would still be here
that study commission on which i served
with senator former senator forrester
and shared by senator carson that looked
at our bidding process
our contract process pretty thoroughly
and we had a lot of you know a lot of
buy-in if you will from contractors uh
is it time for another
review or do you think that the process
is working pretty well because it is a
complex and delicate
operation as you've alluded to
so there was uh i think the commission
that representative schmidt refers to
happened in or around 2015 it was before
my time but it was i think it was when
the theorem was here
um and um
um senator carson has been involved with
procurement for a very long time
it was at that time that statutory
changes were made to 21g
um rsa21g in that section that involves
the procurement process what information
is released to the public it's sort of
why we're here um
i don't know that that a commission
commission is entitled that
there is as a result of that there is a
standing uh meeting on occasion when
needed uh procurement committee that
meets which i think senator carson is
currently the chair of and it involves
various members which we talked to
periodically
um reverse auctions is a thing that
comes up
but can be dealt with um uh
on its own you know gary and his team
and you can tell how knowledgeable gary
is about
about procurement both from from uh his
uh his previous jobs and went to state
um but gary and his team and they meet
with them takamino rakhmatova is the
is the attorney of the attorney
general's office is the procurement
attorney currently
um
and uh you know they meet and they look
at anything that needs tweaking and
changing
part of that comes up as a result of the
process gary talked about where we look
at
um
you know every time we do any kind of a
whether it's reverse auction or a
regular procurement you you do some kind
of a post-mortem on it and say is that
working well or do you think that's
something that's a candidate for doing
it this way instead of this way and um
and so those things are happening i
think right now we're okay without a
commission
but i would say that that
senator carson's committee
um is a very valuable that sort of
standing procurement committee
is a very valuable piece of
infrastructure in the state and i would
i would hate to see that go away
the commission i was alluding to was i
did a lot of work we had we got re-upped
actually from one
term to the next because it was doing so
much important work and we got the
low-hanging fruit in the first go-around
and the the renewal the commission uh
you know
got most of the experience
that's not really relevant to this
particular bill
well that but we have the commitment
you've been answered your questions been
answered
well i'm just saying that it seems to me
like that the
stuff that was devised uh
was effective and he's just alluded to
that so uh i'm i'm glad to hear that
thank you
representative judy has joined us
if you could uh
introduce yourself and say where you are
represent judy
yes he's not really with us when he is
we'll
uh
are there any other questions on
house bill one senate bill 104
anyone else wish to testify on senate
bill 104
raise your hand if you do
and i'm going to introduce amendment
1202h
which is a request of commissioner
arlinghaus
and
i'd like
that's all i can say about it and i
asked him to
describe it to us
hi thank you um
i spoke to representative mcguire and
senator reagan
um about this and this concerns the the
unclassified positions or senior
leadership of the department of
administrative services this is
something you know we've been doing
internally
uh reviewing our process and all that
um
we we're not standardized so people
probably know this
that there are there are more than 10
000 state employees who are full-time
um and
97 98 of them are are are classified
employees they're in that classification
grid and they're hourly employees so for
example i have
an accountant who makes a hundred and
fourteen thousand dollars a year who's
an hourly employee and can't work a 38th
hour in a week
um because it's the it's the way the
system works it's probably not
consistent with the exam non-exempt
rules in in our so commissioners and
directors generally and some of the
senior leadership positions are
unclassified which is a which is a
separate system and a separate grid and
it's the grid controlled by the jcec
which is why i've asked for this to be
appended to this bill
in our area we have some division
directors who are classified and some
are unclassified most are unclassified
and they should be and we've been
converting positions one here and one
there here up periodically where you
where you know four or five years ago we
did risk and benefits that that position
became
uh when cassie was
behind me um was was director there she
became unclassified
um we converted the director plant
property last year
this is a bill to clean all of this up
um tom karen the room with me drafted
the bill for us
um in the best traditions of the statute
and it does two things one
one it takes an it takes an additional i
think it's 11 positions and makes them
unclassified instead of classified these
are all the highest paid senior
positions in the department
and it essentially turns them into what
that means is turns them from an hourly
into a salaried employee
um
and um it does that for
commissioners obviously already there
all the directors and then deputy
directors and analogous positions to
deputy directors for example we have an
internal auditor we have a senior
operational analyst we have a chief
financial officer the fact that my chief
financial officer
is currently an hourly employee
suggests something about how
slightly anachronistic the system
is currently so would take these
positions and it would make them
unclassified it would further divide
them in a standardized way directors and
commissioners would be appointed for a
term
as they as they are mostly today and
then that's how it is pretty much across
state government they are appointed for
a term let's say if let's say a four
year term my case that happens before
your
gary's case it happens to be a four-year
term
um a governor council appointment there
are other positions in
in government who are appointed at it
was referred to as pleasure of the
commissioner which just means they serve
like a like a regular employee in any
job does
um they don't have a term when their
employment expires they just they serve
um
and you can't just you can't just
eliminate them willy-nilly um i couldn't
go i don't like your tie go away
but they serve it the pleasure of the
commissioner it's it's like a job
um and so what we did is to divide them
into two groups directors and
commissioners have a term
and everybody below the director level
that is to say deputies internal auditor
has a pleasure of the commission return
this is the structure we have in other
positions today for example the deputy
director of risk and benefits
is pleasure the commissioner
today the director of risk and benefits
is
a four-year term
and so this does that it is a longer it
is a lot of words
um
but that's what it does and it's a lot
of words because
it changes the statutory reference to
administrator of this to
um to director of this and all of that
and it it cleans the statute up so that
everything matches and there's no an
anachronistic uh referral to something
else
and it's a lot simpler than it looks and
i think it's
at the end of the process we would have
approximately five percent of the
departments 444
authorized
full-time and part-time positions
95 would be classified 5 would be
unclassified
but i'm happy to answer questions about
if anything looks you think it's screwy
or the whole thing sounds weird to you
or maybe
mr arlingham this sounds like a
glorified uh extension of part one
i mean for our department it is
but if we don't if we don't do it in
statute we can't do it
as to
somebody's point earlier i remember who
made this point maybe it was you made
with somebody else about this has to be
done in statute
other questions
i'm impressed there are no other
questions wait a second
hey
madam chair
yes please
my question is
can we see that i don't have that
amendment am i supposed to have that
amendment
it was sent out this morning
this morning okay i'll go look for it
thank you
i think we will need to have a
subcommittee on this
if you have any additional questions and
and something somebody's reading
something and it occurs to them please
feel free to um you know just call me or
send me an email i'm in the state system
which is pretty easy to figure out
charles.m.r house at gas but um
anything you want to know i'm always
here i'm not literally always here but
i'm always available
thank you commissioner we've dug up a
few questions representative bailey
hi
the original 104
fna had a part
has a fiscal note that mentions a part
three which is not in it deleted by the
senate okay so then this amendment has
nothing to do that adds a part three has
nothing to do with that
totally new different unique parts right
thank you
representatives
uh thank you madam chair um
just a general question i haven't looked
over all of this in detail i kind of
skimmed it but uh
it has in statute things like the first
page on line 14 the commissioner shall
nominate my appointment
for appointment by the governor et
cetera um is there anything in here that
changes um the term or anything else
about any of the
appointed positions other than whether
they're classified or not classified
um the the only there are two ver
they're two very slight changes we have
an education and training officer
um who is a uh
functionally a bureau chief of the
division of personnel for the bureau of
education and training and we have a um
senior operational analyst which is a
which is an analytical position
um
for for analyzing government you could
think of it as
vaguely budget related
those positions currently serve a term
but because under this schematic they
would not uh they would become serving
at the pleasure of however because each
of those positions has someone in them
there's a paragraph in it which says
that the um they will serve up their
term
because you can't change that and um uh
the next person or their next term they
would they would convert to the to the
new system but other than that there are
no changes to people's terms
yes those are
those paragraphs are on page five
all right and
other questions comments
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on this amendment
seeing none
i will close the hearing and i believe
this will go to representative pearson's
subcommittee
because
they've only got one bill so far
and
since representative pearson is not here
we'll schedule it at a later time
it is
not yet 11
so representative broda
you have a motion for us
senate bill 15
yes
um
i move
uh the amendment on senate bill
15 and let me get the amendment number
it's amendment number one five five h
yes
we are moving into executive session
115h right
a short break will everybody find their
amendments
somewhere
it should be
it was sent by ols i can give you the
date that we received at the email
it was sent to us but um by ols on
the 20th of april
[Music]
oh i'm sorry just a moment just a second
it was sent to you on that day i'm not
sure it went to the whole committee
i just sent it to everybody um
a few seconds ago
thank you for the update
so it could be in the top of your box
and not somewhere
all right so would you care to speak to
your amendment representative
yes this um
amendment excuse me includes the um
most recent
codes um that were
not included in the bill that was
submitted to the
committee
and also um
harmonizes this
bill
with the house bill that we passed
earlier in the session i believe it was
house bill 72
correct
wait a second is there a second
actually i'll second it
i don't wish to speak to it
are there any is there any discussion
questions or comments on the amendment
i will say i will say that i checked
this with the fire marshal and he agrees
that this is the latest set of
amendments that were approved by the
fire control board so this would bring
senate bill 15 up to date
i did it
any other comments questions
represent allegro i'm sorry thank you
for recognizing me madam charm um i
apologize but i'm struggling to bring
this back into my memory
could um
someone anyone just provide a few
sentences as a reminder
as i as i look for in my hard drive okay
the
changes to the state building code are
required to be in statute
these amendments have been reviewed and
approved by the technical experts
on the building code review board and
the fire control board and we are
ratifying their decisions
any other uh comments questions concerns
in that case the motion is to adopt
amendment um
111 to 5h yes
1155h who is who was speaking
all right somebody didn't speak
any other comments questions discussion
seeing none the clerk can call the role
on the adoption of the amendment
representative roy
yes
the clerk ots representative pearson
not here
representative jacob
yes
representative lekkis yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative lonzaro
yes
representative santo nistaso
representative goalie
yes and madam chair does representative
roy have to be on camera
uh yes
good point yes there can you see me now
we can
can you see me now
representative show it
yes sorry to say we can see you in sunny
florida
representative schuett votes yes
representative judy
we
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative
representative o'brien
o'brien
uh oh he's not at his desk
not here when the question is put i
guess
the chair
yes
it looks like 17-0
right the amendment is adopted
representative you have a motion
yes
i recommend otpa for senate bill 115.
is there a second
that's senate bill 15 right
correct yes did i say house bill sorry
oh you said cynical 115 i think you got
the number
all right is there any further
discussion on the bill as amended
seeing none in that case the clerk will
call the role
yes
representative
representative about me
yes in the fullness of time
representative judy votes yes
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellowes
yes
representative
representative o'brien
has not returned represent chair
yes
the same 17-0 all right
consent object to consent
okay seeing none represent if you could
get me the
uh report in the next day or so i
appreciate it
i will madam chair
um could i also comment that
we had agreed as a committee that we
would adopt
the um building codes
three years after they were
implemented and so
it would be time next year to adopt the
building code would that be correct
correct
okay
yes and i believe the building code
review board has moved on to considering
amendments to the
2018 code so they're adopted in fullness
and i expect that one of us will be
approached to bring such a bill in for
next year
perfect thank you
sounds good
while we're talking about building codes
we have
senate bill 106.
i'm going to move
i want to pass with amendment
h is there a second
madam chair
yes
i i believe we did vote on that bill
previously
do we not have to revisit that vote
before we can amend it
you're absolutely correct representative
in that case i move to reconsider the
vote on senate bill 106.
second
okay seconded by i believe
representative schmidt
no no is that who is representative roy
roy oh okay
so
the reason we're reconsidering it is so
that we can
change the
duties of the committee which after we
passed this bill we point we realized
that it needed
additional work and that's what that's
what that amendment does
so
if we would like to to consider the
amendment we should vote in favor of
reconsideration if you just want to get
it out of our hair we can
vote against reconsideration
so any discussion representative
can you please refresh my memory what is
it that we're changing in the bill
what's specifically about the commission
i'm i'm drawing a blank here we're
adding
to the duties of the commission
we're adding the duties that they shall
make recommendations for establishing a
process for the adoption of new editions
of national or model codes and
amendments
will include consideration of
establishing a permanent statutory
committee for that purpose
i remember that you did talk about that
right the original vote was 12 to 7
and most of the objections were that we
weren't
thoroughly examining the process
representative
jess
send out the amendment again uh yes
uh excuse me miss marlin would you uh
resend the amendment
i have i have it should be on the top of
your your emails
yes well yes
represent our fellows
oh
so
yeah i'm just lost here so the bill is
senate bill 106 correct
correct
in the
and so i'm just waiting to get the
amendment here so okay
it was sent out uh
three minutes ago so
yeah
and representative pearson is with us
uh yes madam chairman i'm i'm here uh
and i'm certainly not against you
excellent
i suppose i should let you know that
your subcommittee has received
senate bill 104 with the amendment and
you should schedule a meeting
so madam chair if this amendment should
pass
that
the um
would the statutory committee
supersede
the
legislation of the building codes the
adoption by legislation of the building
codes or where they come to the to the
edna with a recommendation
that's for the study committee to decide
we're just saying they should look
really hard how we adopt
building codes and building code updates
because the current method is
let's just say it's inefficient
yeah but we're getting way off the topic
here the motion is reconsideration
correct
but the reason for reconsideration is to
consider the amendment
okay yeah
so it sounds totally support that
most people have
have appear to have read the amendment
so
yes
the amendment
excuse me
motion to reconsider so
okay so i'll ask questions about the
amendment after
right
there we go
thank you representative schmidt for
keeping us on track
i want that motion that at that action
note noted
i just found the amendment but i'm good
to go on the vote for reconsider
thank you very much representative
phillips
any other comments on reconsideration
okay though
in that case the clerk will call the
role on reconsideration
in consideration of sb 105
representative roy
yes 106.
i'm one code behind
representative roy
have to unmute yourself before you can
blow
yeah sorry i was trying to float in
silence this is just for uh representing
the goalie i know yes i want to make
sure you can see me right now so
we we certainly can
rubbing it in man rubbing it
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lonzara
yes
representative
representative goalie
yes
representing
representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative grayson
representative
yes
representative o'brien
yes and the chair yes
so we have my
reconsideration
fine so we are now reconsidering our
vote of what to pass
on senate bill
106. and
i believe it now would be relevant
to
to move it
would it be relevant to just move
adoption of the amendment since we have
not to pass
recognition yes okay thank you
parliamentarian
and i move amendment 1105
h
who was that
representative roy beat me to it
okay no that's
and i will say that this expands the
duties of the commission to address the
concerns that were raised at the
previous executive session
because
we want to make sure that we look at
this process again
i think that's important
representative roy do you wish to speak
to your second
no that's okay i think he said it
okay representative
thank you madam chair
my question is
i see in the amendment that calls for
three senators
i'm guessing they have agreement to that
number as we know sometimes it's
difficult to get
senators to attend such commissions we
absolutely do have agreement
representative schuett that's the bill
that came to us from the senate
and i know that senator morris has been
vigilant about making sure that at least
the number of senators are required for
any study committee to vote for
thank you i just wanted to be sure that
they were aware that
this amendment was coming to us we're
just agreeing with representative
thank you um
when you introduced it you said it
expanded
the duties of the commission i mean what
committee oh
my microphone that's fine
so basically this
establishes a committee to study
this whole process and um you know all
they would do is uh
report their findings i recommend
legislation if they think there needs to
be which would then come to zulita in
dna
the
intent of the senators when they brought
brought this to us was that this year
the committee would
work with the building code review board
to develop a bill to adopt the 18
version of the codes
and while they're at it they'd figure
out a better way to do it
that's all right
any other questions comments discussion
seeing none
the motion is to adopt amendment
1105 h to senate bill 106
one ready the
representative pearson votes yes
yes
representative allegra yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara
yes
representative santa mustafo
representative
yes
representative judy
schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative
yes representative broda
yes
representative o'brien
and the chair yes
right at 19-0 the amendment is adopted
all right and
and i will move on to pass with
amendment
is there any further discussion
on the bill as amended
seeing none in that case
with amendment representative
yes
representative
representative schultz
yes
representative fellows
yes representative grace
yes
representative grota
representative o'brien
yes and the chair
yes
consent
any objections to consent it's 19 to
zero
foreign
i have a motion on senate bill 33
which is relative to native american
name restoration
and i'd like to move in expedient to
legislate
a second back end
who was before him
no terry was before me
okay i'll give you credit this time it's
it's not really a race
yep
and i'd like to say that
that this bill came to us as amended by
the senate the sponsor brought in a new
amendment to the hearing
and then all the people that
are claimed to be involved spoke in
opposition to the bill
so i've got to say it is not ready for
prime time by any means
and i think that the
stakeholders need to get together and
agree if any changes need to be made
i'm not sure they are needed we do have
a process
so i'm recommending you just
up this bill and that's the sponsors
representative schmidt do you wish to
speak to your second well i certainly
will second the remarks you just made uh
and
for me the most important thing here is
to have the buy-in of the indigenous
people of new hampshire of whom i'm
recently informed there are maybe as
many as ten thousand abundantly in new
hampshire right now um
and uh
there is
uh
the the commission
itself is
is in some doubt with regard to
uh
the position they have and they're not a
majority on the commission of abunaki
and this is something where
uh they their voice needs to be heard
and they are still developing even the
people i've been speaking with are still
developing their position on renaming of
things and so forth so
your earlier remark about
getting them to have a unified position
is absolutely on on point so high tl is
the right way to go here
representative
yes and i will agree with what's been
said this far and as i understand it the
renaming process
as it exists today actually isn't
working
and why fix something that isn't broken
excellent representative schuett
uh thank you madam chair i am
i guess i'm just echoing what's been
said already
i was going to originally
suggest retention of this bill but my
question would be
if
through some miracle
they come up with an agreement for a
bill for next year
do you feel that killing this bill in
any way would
put that in jeopardy
it might
but it wasn't
past the senate so
they could introduce it through the
senate i believe
and
i hope it would be different enough that
we could accept it in the house
thank you
i think it also if they
more generically address the process for
name changes
rather than
that would be different enough that they
should do it
thank you very much
madam chair i would not be in favor of
retention only because
there's so there were so many
significant issues with this bill but i
really think that that's addressed by
the people who are involved and i would
be hesitant to think something
that as a as representative schultz said
is already working so if we have a
system
that's functional
i would be very hesitant to change that
thank you
other comments questions
all right
seeing none the motion has been
expedient to legislate on senate bill 33
and
yes
representative
representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative
representatives
yes
representative o'brien
the chair yes
consent
any objections to consent
right seeing now we'll put that one on
consent
right
anyone else have a motion on a bill that
can be resolved as quickly as this one
i move that you stop interrupting my
panic a lot of times
[Laughter]
in that case we uh
since nobody else seems to have any
ideas we will break now we're resuming
at one o'clock
sharp
for senate bill 155
and it's non-germaine amendment
[Laughter]
yes representative o'brien uh through
you may i ask if i can receive those
amendments i tried looking on the
website and i'm having a difficulty
and retrieving those amendments so i
wonder if they could be sent to me
during the law i'm sorry i didn't
you're trying to read the amendment on
the
uh on senate bill 155
yes ma'am
okay i believe it was sent out um ms
smarling will probably get you an update
sure i'd be happy to send resend the
amendments to everybody just to cover
all bases
thank you very much i appreciate that
put them at the top of our email
which is the one we're doing today
and also the
non-germane amendment to senate bill
133 from representative walmer
yes please
yes
madam campaign
add me to the mailing list i would
appreciate it
yes that's a good idea good point sorry
representative grassy
okay
no problem at all thank you
my question is totally uh what beach is
representative roy
i think i am
in your honor i'm taking my hat off and
putting my glasses up
all right we will uh adjourn we'll be
back at one o'clock sharp
and
thank you all for for
this morning
good morning's work
there's a quick enough looking at it but
we have time this afternoon with um
exactly the senate bill 57 the pharmacy
technique
okay
um
damn it
we were just talking about that were you
what i loved was
in
and pulls his coat down and pulls out
his gun this will get you in solid with
your boss yeah that's great
yeah they were going to sacrifice him
yeah he was in shame
he gives the guns to gut
i don't know
you and i started it
all right
movie night is is over
and uh
i'm opening the hearing
for senate bill 155
senator bradley who is the prime sponsor
signed up to testify but i don't see him
oh there he is
senator bradley
oh good afternoon i wasn't sure you were
ready for me i apologize
uh thank you very much chairwoman
uh maguire and members of the committee
uh pleasure to be here
for the record jeff bradley
district three
so
i
sponsored this bill at the request of
governor sununu
the intent of the bill was
to enable
the governor to
end some of the emergency orders
by
placing into statute some of the
provisions
of
the covet pandemic initiatives
that
could go into statute enabling the
ending of some of the emergency orders
this bill was much longer when it was
first introduced and the senate winnowed
it down to
the nine provisions that are in the bill
and i think that um even though there
was quite a bit of controversy
initially about this bill that
controversy has largely been dissipated
because of what's in the bill and i'll
just very briefly touch on
you know those provisions that are in
the bill the first section
deals with the nurse practice act and it
allows
long-term care facilities
um
to create the position of a temporary
health partner
the second
senator
yes ma'am
could we ask questions of each section
because i they don't appear to be very
much related
uh
you can sure whatever you would like to
do
all right thank you in that case this
this is to be a permanent new level of
licensure or not
hang on let me refer back to the end of
the bill
um
the prospective repeals
this would be permanent yes
thank you
and it
i this position i think if you look at
line 18 of the bill it's designed to
assist
uh lnas in the daily tasks
that um
they have to perform in long-term care
facilities
okay
thank you
yep the second section
allows
the office of professional licensure to
issue emergency
licenses to
you know the following applicants a
medical provider
that
is no longer active in the state a
medical provider
in another jurisdiction
um
someone accredited by the accreditation
council for graduate medical education
so
it'll it it just expands
um the pool if you will of licensed
practitioners and i think tries to
resolve some of the
workforce issues that we have around
healthcare positions
moving along
on and that would be a permanent um
change also moving along
that section excuse me section five on
the uh emts
uh we put that was in a separate house
bill
if that's in a separate house bill then
i think it would not be necessary in
this bill provided
uh madam chair you work with senator
carson make sure that um
you know it's gonna go forward in the in
the senate which it shouldn't be a
problem
thank you
section three at the bottom of page
three
um deals with the definition of pharmacy
practice and that allows
the dispensing of the
emergency use authorization of covet
shots
we have
made it
easier over the years for
trained pharmacists to be able to
administer vaccines
this just adds to that list
section four on page four
section four on page four allows the
um
pharmacist to administer a covet test
section five at the bottom of page 4
administration again of covet vaccines
section 6
is a temporary
license for out-of-state pharmacies
section seven
um
a number
of summer camps
are
permitted under pre-existing
conditions vis-a-vis the zoning in the
particular communities that they have
generally speaking
if you are unable to
[Music]
utilize a non-conforming use for
a period of a year you could lose that
non-conforming use
status this allows the protection for
pre-existing
non-conforming uses for summer camps i
think that's a very important
provision for
summer camps throughout new hampshire
um section eight
this was um
put into the bill by the senate because
of the difficulty sometimes of
completing
um construction work uh for
um
on a permit to make sure that um
those permits move forward
and don't just expire because of covid
and then
lastly
section nine
um
is a temporary expansion of outdoor
dining through 2023.
so
that was something that um i think most
people would agree in new hampshire has
worked pretty well
the senate
determined that it should be expanded
you know for
that period of two years and then
analyze it again and as you can see
um in the section 10 that section is
repealed
um at the end of 2023
and then
uh
section
[Music]
um
dealing with the
uh
mail order pharmacies
are also repealed on january 31 of 2022
so
that's a summary of the bill and um
thank you very much
thank you are you available to answer
questions
i'll do my best
thank you representative pearson
thank you madam chair
and thank you senator brad
bradley for taking my question uh my
question is it just quickly involves
just section 8 when it comes to school
bus lights
um just to be sure for clarification
this is just adding a provision
to go along with the existing rsa 266
this isn't removing anything
as far as the school bus lights and the
requirements
for warning
representative pearson are you looking
at the bill as amended by the senate i
think that may have been deleted in the
senate
yeah i don't believe that's in there
representative
we took out probably
i
if i recall there were about 30
provisions
in the bill that the governor gave to me
we
because there were some that were fairly
controversial
we did take some of them out
and ended up with the nine provisions
that you see
in the bill
okay
are there other questions for senator i
do like your background though
representative
if you've ever been to manchester
england it will make a whole lot more
sense to you
all right
representative
uh thank you i'm sure so this may just
be that i'm not familiar with the way i
haven't seen before how this is put
together but it's around uh
prospective repeals and the effective
dates um
i mean the way i read it under effective
dates
it's paragraphs one and two of section
10 of section 10. i see
okay never mind
what's that got to figure it out i think
representative thank you madam chair
senator bradley is there anything in the
restaurant outdoor dining area
that would overrule current town
ordinances
i'm just reading it
um
i i you know i suspect the municipal
association is going to testify that's
probably i don't see anything that
overrules the town zoning but that would
be a better question to ask
the municipal association
thank you
representative
thank you madam chair um senator bradley
i'm wondering about section
eight i think i think it is the um
the one about the construction
and i'm wondering
why
this is needed because i would think
that at this point
that most of the municipalities
have been able to
start to
[Music]
address building permits
so why do you believe this is still
needed
i think this is one of those that um you
could be right
but um
i think it's safe to
say that there are probably some
communities where it is necessary and as
i recall
representative the testimony in the
senate there was no
opposition raised by this section
thank you
other questions of the senator
i have a question about the
summer camps
would the
would restricted operations during
should we change it to show that
restricted use during the summer of 2021
does not
un-grandfather them
um
yeah
you know i i don't know what
that's probably a question that the
association of camp directors could
answer better
my assumption is that most camps are
going to be able to open in 2021
um
but it may be wise to say summer of 2020
and 2021 i
i'll leave that up to your discretion
madam chair thank you representative
goalie
thank you manchester um
senator under
section five
administration of covert vaccines
i'm looking under
318 and
um currently on the
318-16b pharmacist administration of
vaccines
currently includes the administration of
covert 19 vaccines and i'm just curious
as to why there's a whole new section
going creating 318 colon 16f when
pharmacists are already allowed to
administer i'm trying to
look through this briefly as we
have this
um you got me on that one
again
we've expanded the
the point was to it to allow the
pharmacist to be able to um
administer the vaccine
and
i
think section 4 deals with a pharmacist
and
section 5 deals with the technician
administration so they
they maybe just covered slightly
differently in the statute so they
needed to be cited one for the
technician and one for the pharmacist
but
perhaps somebody who has more expertise
than i can answer that
i apologize
thank you
representative
yeah i'm looking at 318-16b and it deals
with a pharmacist or pharmacy intern
whereas section 5 of the bill
deals with pharmacy technicians so i
guess it expands into pharmacy
technicians
okay
any further questions for uh senator
bradley
this will be going to subcommittee
um
representative roy seems the most
appropriate
so
so we will look at some of these uh
questions
other questions
see
let me say thank you very much madam
chair and uh always a pleasure
thank you
mr john schmidt signed up to speak on
this bill
hello can you hear me yes
yes we can hear you
please introduce yourself and
talk to us
looks like he muted himself
yeah it does
can you hear me hello
yes we can hear you
okay i'm sorry
i'm at 31 green acres road in keene
my main concern today isn't with the
bill so much as it is with the amended
bill that gives gives that case
mr schmidt we are not discussing that
amendment at the moment we will be
covering it after we've completed the
basic bill and i'll call on you then all
right thank you
all right
is there anyone else who wishes to s to
testify
on the basic bill before the amendment
ah
there she is
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee um for the record lindsay
courtney executive director of the new
hampshire office of professional
licensure and certification
oplc wishes to express its support of
portions of this bill directly impacting
oplc specifically sections two
three and four
um when the covid19 pandemic began
healthcare providers uh quickly moved to
a telehealth platform in order to
prevent and limit the spread of the
virus this of course legally posed a
challenge for the state the practice of
health care is deemed to occur where
their patient is physically located
so providers who typically provided care
for new hampshire patients and border
states such as vermont and massachusetts
suddenly needed a new hampshire license
to continue to legally provide services
to those patients
and to receive reimbursement from
insurance providers for those services
emergency order number 15 authorizes the
agency to issue emergency licenses to
medical providers who have a license in
good standing in another jurisdiction
rather than grant the authority to issue
licenses to individual boards this
consolidated approach permitted the
agency to issue licenses quickly using
one simplified process
at present our time frame for complete
application to licensure is 24 business
hours or less
and today the agency has issued
approximately 222 thousand emergency
license without a fee
63 percent of psychologists in new
hampshire 47 of marriage and family
therapists 45 percent of active licensed
clinical mental health workers and 45
percent of licensed independent clinical
social workers in new hampshire are
practicing with an emergency license
issued by the agency
oplc has encouraged these providers with
an emergency license to obtain permanent
licensure if they intend to continue to
practice in this state
but one of the most frequent questions
we receive is how long the license will
last
at present the emergency order is tied
to the state of emergency which must be
reevaluated every 21 days
codifying the office's ability to issue
these licenses through january 31st of
next year would provide professionals
and facilities with predictability
as to the licensed term
and
to ensure that new hampshire
constituents continue to have access to
the care they need oplc fully supports
section two of this bill
section three as mentioned permits
pharmacists and pharmacy technicians
with certain training to administer the
covenant vaccines and tests
obviously it goes without saying that
our pharmacists and pharmacy techs are
trusted partners in the state's effort
to quickly and effectively combat cobit
accordingly oplc urges your support of
section 3.
and section 4 permits out-of-state
pharmacies to ship investigational drugs
to clinical trial participants who
reside in new hampshire and who are
unable to to retrieve the
investigational drugs from out of state
pharmacies
this emergency order essentially rose
because there are several new hampshire
patients who typically travel to
massachusetts hospitals for
participation in clinical trials where
they receive investigational drugs such
as dana farmer
when the transition to telehealth
platform occurred massachusetts
healthcare facilities were seeking to
continue to provide such drugs to their
patients located in the future in order
to ensure the continuity of care for
this vulnerable and limited population
oplc believes this emergency order must
continue during the copa 19 pandemic
thank you for the opportunity to provide
comments and i am happy to answer any
questions you may have
thank you are there questions
from the committee
representative
um thank you uh
i'm chair
so on section three the
the pharmacist pharmacies uh the one for
uh
that's
that's the one for the out of state
pharmacies being able to ship in
is that limited to just uh cobia 19
related
i'm sorry are you talking about the
administration of the testing or are you
talking about investigational drugs
investigational drugs that's the bottom
of page five i don't think okay thank
you so um
i guess the question gets into
[Music]
the definition of um
limiting this to investigational drugs i
mean i have a
personal situation where i get uh
specialty eye drops for dry eye that
were made down at mass eye and ear
and i had to travel down there quarterly
to have that done
which posed a problem i was able to find
someplace up here that did it
but um
you know i guess the question is what's
the definition of
investigational drugs because there are
some drugs that are made
uh specifically for a person in
particular those drops are made out of
my own blood so i can't get them as a
general
you know from a normal pharmacy
and would those be covered and if not
you know why not
yeah i think that definition would have
to be fleshed out in in rulemaking um i
do think that the situation you posed um
would meet that test of being an
investigational drug typically i think
the way we've looked at it throughout
the emergency
the state of emergency is that if it's
if it's a drug that's um
essentially made for a particular
patient
um that's not necessarily goes through
the fda approval process that usually
meets the definition of um
in
an investigational drug but i do think
that that would need further
clarification
to make sure that we're
you know encompassing all types of
scenarios the common situation that this
has posed is really um cancer patients
or people undergoing clinical trials
that have that were typically going down
to boston for their services um and then
the move to the telehealth platform that
that was the most common scenario that
we that we encountered throughout the
state of emergency
thank you
other questions
excuse me representative phillips
thank you madam chair
um
director courtney
uh could you please
tell me about section one
because section one doesn't have an
expired date
in these temporary health partners
i'm thinking are not going to be
temporary anymore
but they seem to have um
duties that are close to what an lna
has and there doesn't seem to be any
mechanism by which
your agency would
know who these people are
and and i'm also just wondering how
how they would be classified in terms of
in
you know what category of employee
because i'm thinking that
the long-term care facilities i assume
they're reporting to somebody how
they're about their staffing and how
many
rns and they have in lpns and all of
this
any insight you have on that i'd
appreciate
yeah thank you for that question
um the emergency order pertaining to
temporary health partners was the result
of much collaboration with stakeholders
including the agency and the board of
nursing
um
so typically so new hampshire state of
new hampshire licenses lnas other states
have certified nursing assistants others
have
just basically anybody who meets their
criteria and it's approved by a board of
nursing in order for cms to reimburse
long-term care facilities for the
services at minimum um the lna or cna or
whoever is functioning in that capacity
requires um an eight hour course some
states have taken the approach that an
eight-hour course is sufficient to be an
lna or a cna new hampshire has taken the
position i think rightfully so that to
be an lna um you need a hundred hours
which is really not a lot of time
so um there was a lot of discussion
throughout the emergency um the state of
emergency particularly at the beginning
of that how do we get more
healthcare workers into our long-term
care facilities
questions were raised about whether or
not we lowered the existing standard for
an lna to eight hours from 100 hours to
eight hours i can tell you that a lot of
stakeholders
the board of nursing included thought
that that was not protective of the
public
um
a lot of the um a lot of the complaints
we received currently um are
disproportionately uh related to lna
care and so the the thought was that by
decreasing standards we could increase
um potential harm to patient care
so when um stakeholders collaborated
regarding the temporary health partner
it was clear that this temporary health
partner should should not be functioning
as an lna but they should be assisting
um the lna
and um and with that language in place
the board and the agency were able to be
and i believe the department although i
don't want to speak for dhhs we're able
to be supportive of that language
um so this really codifies that um
that collaborative effort and allows um
people without the lna training to
to enter the workforce in a long-term
care facility but they're not permitted
to function
um as an lna outside of going through
the lna application process
i believe there is some legislation
pending that would um that would permit
one to essentially utilize their
experience
as a temporary health partner as a
mechanism to transition to lna
that was something that the board of
nursing did support and the office does
support as well provided that um that
they do meet the minimum qualifications
although it's important to note that cms
regulations
do require for reimbursement purposes
that this um
that an lna
attend a board approved program so when
you're drafting that sort of legislation
you need to make clear that um
that whatever education or experience
this temporary health partner has
um needs to be board approved i think
that kind of goes above that kind of
goes outside the scope of what you're
asking for but um that's that's the
background behind this temporary health
partner
thank you that's exactly the kind of
thing i'm looking for i'm just wondering
if you have any insight
into
i'm not sure where this is in statute
because it seems to me that temporary
shouldn't be part of the title anymore
yeah so this would this would amend 326
was that which is the board of nursing
practice act um
and
i i would agree with you if it's i guess
it is temporary i should throw it out
there it is temporary to the extent that
per cms regulations
i hold on i don't want to overspeak
if they are functioning as an lna which
they are not so never mind i'm i'm just
going to never mind sorry
the
licensure of temporary health
partners to lnas is covered under one of
the sections of senate bill 133 it will
be in subcommittee tomorrow
representative fellows if you want to
participate representative goalie
thank you madam chair
uh a couple of questions if i may
first
are you here testifying on behalf of the
office of oplc or
both the office and the board of
pharmacy
that's the office
okay
and
follow
um
i just want to
confirm that the boards are acting
independently of the office when they
make the decisions they are making
is that true
yeah i mean it depends on what the
decision is but yeah they have their own
independent regulatory authority
all right because that just the concern
i heard about your testimony was
if the board and the office both agree
on a change and my concern is what
happens if you disagree
i don't recall that part of my testimony
representative could you clarify just so
that i can clarify
there was something that just came up
and you stated that the board of nursing
supported and the office support
yeah which is why i made that
distinction that both the board and the
office supported because i worked very
closely with the board of nursing on
this issue and i can represent that the
board of nursing was supportive of that
thank you
um miss courtney last week we did hear
house bill 133
and
i'm just wondering
which was actually which was to include
the the hours that people were working
towards the 100 hours
because at the time we didn't have
enough lnas
so now what we're asking to do is we're
we're creating
this position of temporary health care
partner health partner
and this person
would work so what would this this
person would work under
was would this be somebody who's
equivalent to an lna
no um this person works alongside an lna
and assess the lna um when we were
working with stakeholders to come up
with this language that was one thing
that the office dhhs and um the board of
nursing wanted to make clear that this
person wasn't functioning as an lna um
because they had only
they will on day one only have taken an
eight-hour course that doesn't include
hands-on clinical experience
follow-up follow-up
is the work that this person does
would that fall under the jurisdiction
of
the bill house bill 133 whereas if they
worked for the 100 hours then they would
be qualified as an lna
so if both bills were to pass then yes
theoretically one could be a temporary
health partner and work for 100 hours i
believe and then if if that language
permitted it um they could transition to
a licensed nursing assistant and i i'm
planning on talking or hopefully
speaking in subcommittee tomorrow
regarding this and the the only caveat
is that that language and sb 133 must be
changed in order to allow medicaid
reimbursement for those individuals um
such that you know 100 hours is deemed
the equivalent of board approval i can
make that um request during the
subcommittee but there there is a
technical change that that must be
made in order to prevent medicaid
reimbursement
follow-up follow-up
and how would this part of this bill
with the temporary health worker
fall
be coordinated with house bill 133 that
would allow the 100 hours that they do
to come towards the l a is that in this
bill or is this
how is that going to work
yeah that's a separate bill so as i
understand how the two bills would work
together if they both passed this bill
permits um the the existence of a
temporary health partner to continue
because right now if you're performing
these activities
um one can argue that it falls within
the scope of the board of nursing so um
this bill would make clear that one is
permitted to perform those activities as
long as they have an eight-hour course
then they could accrue the hundred hours
and then if there was another statute
that permitted them to use those hundred
hours to transition to licensure and
they could do so at that time
welcome to your last question
follow-up
do you have any do you are there any
other bills that you know that haven't
come to this committee that involves
this type of
of um licensure with lnas
not to my knowledge um there is the and
i don't i forget off the top of my head
but there is a bill that's pending um
that would allow emts
and
those with military occupational
specialties to obtain permanent license
as a licensure as an lna um and i
believe that obviously would come before
edna as well but that's something that
the office does support
yes
that particular bill passed the house
earlier and is currently in the senate
yes that's correct i do remember that
thank you
okay representative schuett
thank you madam chair
thank you for taking a question miss
courtney uh i'm concerned about the new
section
that allows it's page 4 line 30
that allows
pharmacist technicians
to administer
covid vaccines
it's been my experience over the years
getting flu shots
that i always have to wait
to get an appointment to get my flu
vaccine
from the practicing pharmacist
to me this looks like a pretty major
change
and i'm curious what the thinking is uh
going forward with
i don't see this in the repeals
yeah so this is consistent with existing
emergency orders that are also
consistent with the federal health and
human services guidelines that um that
were issued essentially we expanded the
ability of certain health care workers
um to administer the coven 19 vaccines
in order to obviously roll out the
vaccines quickly um
so
pharma pharmacy technicians do presently
um have the capability of administering
the kobit 19 vaccines under the
supervision of a licensed pharmacy and
are actually doing that this bill is
limited to the copen 19 vaccine um and
it still has to be um under the
supervision of
a licensed pharmacist
so um you know oplc supports it to the
extent that you know it's clinically
appropriate i think um i think that the
fact that
nationwide we've utilized pharmacy
technicians in this capacity to assist
with coca-19 demonstrates that in this
circumstance it is clinically
appropriate to do so
follow up and chair
follow up
thank you um i understand during the
pandemic uh the need for this
but we're hearing that
it's likely folks are going to have to
get
probably annual boosters of this
same as my flu shot
and so this is going to be
an exception for what this one specific
vaccine going forward
i just don't understand why it's not
going to be repealed at the end of
hopefully at the end of the pandemic
period
representative that's a good question to
discuss in the subcommittee
thank you
representative goalie
thank you manager i had one more
question before that i neglected to ask
um
you had stated that
there had been
i
want to say 22 000
licenses administered under the
emergency orders is that correct yes
and that was at no cost
yep that's correct
follow-up
so do you believe that there should be
some sort of a cost even on a temporary
licensure due to the fact that there is
a cost overrun associated with the
boards processing these and the office
processing that number of applications
um that this is being passed on to
current new hampshire licensees and it's
not fair
so you raised a good question our
representative i can tell you when we
first were
working toward emergency licensure we
did not anticipate the large
influx of emergency license applications
um in terms of resources yeah we do we
have expended great deal of resources
just manually processing licenses
um
there is a provision in 310a that is
similar to this that once the state of
emergency ends
that would allow the office a
professional licensure to issue
temporary licenses for 120 days based on
the same criteria and it is our
expectation that we would charge a
nominal fee for that um for that
temporary license
but um given the public health crisis
that we were facing um obviously the
agency you know in conjunction with the
governor's office um and working with
the attorney general's office you know i
i think that it was paramount that we
get people in here in order to assist
with the cover 19 pandemic
thank you and it would be nice hopefully
if some of the emergency money that came
in would be handed over to the office to
help out processing these emergency
licenses
we will take that under advisement
representative pearson
thank you chair
my my question
miss miss courtney um has to do with the
the simple pecking order if you will
lnas are kind of well they're not kind
of they're at the bottom bottom of the
of the uh for the pecking order here and
and their pay is certainly reflected of
that fact uh
you know the pay for lnas is is
bluntly horrid so this temporary health
care provider that's going to be in
essence a new sort of level below an lna
what on earth is the expected pay
that you would see
for this job considering the fact that
lnas are barely making by as it is
yeah thanks for that question to be
honest with you i don't know this uh
this
emergency order was widely sought out
after by the new hampshire healthcare
association
the agency and the board had um
some concerns regarding public
protection
my general thoughts regarding the um the
pay is i think we're never going to see
the numbers of lnas increase if we don't
address the pay situation um oftentimes
i think people view it as a licensure
problem it's not a licensure problem um
given that the work that they do
um you know they get paid at the same
rate as you know somebody working at
dairy queen on certain you know
instances i think that that obviously is
a huge part of the problem so i don't
know what these temporary health
partners are getting paid i i would i
think that somebody from you know
healthcare association or um
you know a long-term care facility could
better address that
follow-up manager
so
in your opinion then are we just not
creating a classification that justify
paying people less and less and less and
less to do the same work and i know you
may not be able to answer that because
it's an opinion question
yeah i mean my opinion is that we need
to pay lnas more and i think that that
the rate of alanis is probably tied to
the medicaid reimbursement rate which
it's totally outside my wheelhouse so i
think but i think if you want to resolve
that problem that's something that the
state has to look at
further questions from the committee
represent bailly
miss courtney
is there any reason why these first four
temporary licenses just couldn't be
extended indefinitely
as opposed to having a sunset
they don't have a song oh okay well
thank you
makes it easier other questions for uh
ms courtney
seeing none thank you very much
thank you for your time
representative cushman
hi thank you madam chair and thank you
members of the committee
i am here to
uh testify on the amendment the
non-domain amendment excuse me we aren't
there yet okay so i'll call you later
when we get to um i do have something to
mention on the bill though oh please
please say so um so for i'm on the
health and human services and elderly
affairs committee in the house
and as far as the section in this bill
on pharmacy technicians and pharmacists
um
we already hashed out and passed i
believe it was on the consent calendar
uh a bill that does exactly what that
section does
and
if you haven't send us that information
we would love to have it
sure
okay it's hb572 and it um
it
let me see 19 to zero and was on consent
okay thank you we will uh
uh
we'll consider deleting this section in
deference to the house bill
uh good afternoon can anybody hear me
okay
yes
uh thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is rob tardiff uh i
represent the new hampshire department
of environmental services and i have to
first apologize for not being
very familiar with this bill it was just
brought to our attention
a little over an hour ago
but i would like to speak to and i'm not
sure if this is the time frame or not
and if it's not i apologize for that as
well
uh but we'd like to speak to the
expansion of outdoor seating
part of this bill is this is this the
appropriate time to express a few
concerns
yes
uh again i'm with the subsurface systems
bureau i'm the administrator of the
subsurface systems bureau and
the
responsibility of this program is
regarding
onsite wastewater or septic systems
and the allowance for the expansion of
outdoor seeding
could potentially in those
in those facilities who who are on
on-site waste water
uh versus municipal sewer for instance
uh that could
uh put them in violation of their state
approvals
for their septic systems
so we'd like to
at least have those those concerns taken
into consideration and as i've been
listening
i understand that this may be going to
sub-committee so
if if it's appropriate i can i can
attend those subcommittee meetings or i
can
uh
give a couple of of our concerns now
thank you well i think the idea that we
need to consider
overloading septic systems is important
uh what what is your other issue
uh well it's it's it's not necessarily
only wastewater regarding the
department's concern but it's also water
supply
if these facilities are on
a private water supply or private well
the additional draw from those wells
could
bring those facilities into a different
set of regulations regarding water
supply
as far as the on-site wastewater goes
you know the
the systems are are sized based on the
on a proposed flow or an existing flow
and those flows are based on number of
seats in a restaurant
so of course if you increase the seats
you therefore increase the flow
uh
the septic system isn't
would not then be sized appropriately
it could uh encourage or or
the system may be
forced into premature failure
as a result of some sort of
extended loading
uh the septic tanks
may not be sized appropriately
uh the grease traps may not be sized
appropriately
and then everything that the systems are
based on is is what's called lot loading
and lot loading is a
it's a site characteristic it's a it's
based on soils it's based on slopes and
ledge and a number of other
site-specific characterizations
and if
if the increased
number of seats which would increase
that load it may exceed
what the
lot that the
facility is on it may exceed that lots
potential or or ability to manage that
wastewater
well thank you i think you is
isn't this the amendment madam chair
no the
the outdoor lining the expansion of
outdoor dining for
several years is in the basic bill
okay thank you
so that needs would need to be
considered at the subcommittee level if
needed definitely a subcommittee
material
at that point okay thank you mr charter
for the information
again thank you for letting me speak and
again apologize i tried to
to register to speak and everything was
happening so quickly i'm not sure i did
it correctly so thank you for letting me
speak
matt hood
yes
recognize just unmute yourself
[Music]
thank you very much madam chair sorry
for the delay uh in figuring out the
mute and unmute buttons
i trust you can hear me now
i actually
recognized that there was an amendment
that was being offered that you're not
speak taking speaking to now
but i did want to um respond to jeff uh
representative goalie's question
to the extended introduce yourself first
of course my name is matthew hood
i'm the vice president of government
relations at dartmouth hitchcock
dartmouth hitchcock
is obviously on the border with vermont
and the state of vermont has issued
essentially temporary licensures
licenses through
march of 2022
and there's not a fee to that i can't
speak to massachusetts and maine though
i assume miss courtney could
or find out the information to that um
so i just wanted to share that
information for
your consideration about the question
about fees
thank you
lisa english
good afternoon
madam chair members of the committee my
name is lisa english i'm the special
advisor for covid 19 response and
recovery i'm here on behalf of the
governor's office um as you've heard
senate bill 155 was designed as a
vehicle to codify selected emergency
orders put in place as a result of the
pandemic
the legislation's designed to provide
the state with that ability to continue
these targeted measures as we move into
the next stage of the pandemic in
recovery of the pandemic
senator bradley and director courtney
have addressed i think
almost all of the questions that i
certainly would be situated to be able
to speak to the only addition i would
add is that
with regard to the pharmacy technicians
on october 20th of 2020 the u.s
department health
of health and human services issued a
guidance document recommending that
pharmacy technicians be allowed to
administer the covid vaccine the cova 19
vaccine and that's part of an emergency
order it's emergency order number 79
that that led to that provision in this
particular bill
i'm happy to answer any questions but i
believe any of the notes that i had for
unanswered questions have been addressed
by the earlier speakers but i wanted to
make sure you knew i was available
okay representative schuett has a
question
thank you
chair um thank you ms english since you
addressed the
question that i proposed um
my issue is not so much
enabling pharmacy technicians to
administer vaccines during the crisis
period my issue is that it's not
included in the repeals
and we're hearing that it's likely that
these vaccines will have to be
administered
annually the same as flu vaccines
and
this
this is a new provision to allow
these technicians to administer this
specific vaccine shot without repealing
it at the end of the pandemic
so thank you for that question um i
don't believe the guidance from the
federal government was limiting it in
time either however
this the goal of this particular
legislation was to offer that vehicle
for these discussions um so
we don't take a stance at this point as
to whether or not that should be
included as at a sunset date or as it
currently stands without a sunset date
thank you for that clarification
representative
uh thank you madam chair
so uh related question and that is um
you know would there be any reason not
to any objection
to just expanding this to the pharmacy
technicians being able to administer uh
you know any you know basic
vaccine thank you for that question i
would defer to um to oplc as well as um
the board of pharmacy as to what would
be appropriate for pharmacy techs to be
able to administer
other
other questions from his english
seeing none is there anyone else who
wishes wishes to testify on the basic
bill not the amendment
so please raise your hand
okay we've got someone
ms burns you can unmute yourself and
talk to us
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee thank you for hearing my
testimony my name is margaret burns i'm
the executive director of the new
hampshire municipal association and we
do not have a position on senate bill
155 but we do have a couple of comments
and i would also like to respond to some
of the questions asked at the beginning
of the hearing the first question on
senate bill 155 is sort of a technical
one that's probably better for
the subcommittee it's relative to
sections seven and eight the sections on
summer camps and construction
we would suggest that if this bill
passes those sections not be codified
and instead be passed as a session law
meaning that they would not be published
in the published versions of the law but
they would still have the full force and
effect of the law and the reason for
that sort of technical suggestion is
that those sections relate to very
specific discrete issues and not
codifying them particularly the section
on summer camps which would be added to
rsa chapter 674 would help prevent
some already very long and complex
statutes from not becoming longer and
more complex so that's a very small
technical change
i do want to comment and respond to the
question about senate bill 155 and it's
sort of interaction with town zoning and
town ordinances
and this would be the expansion of
outdoor dining section
the bill does recognize a local role in
the approval process for expansion of
outdoor dining in the section that talks
about expansion that would occur on
shared spaces or on a shared space and
this would include expansion onto
municipal roads expansion that goes into
the sidewalks into municipal street
parking spaces or other municipally
owned or managed property but there
could be
clearer language if this legislation
were to pass there could be clearer
language about the applicability of
local rules regulations and ordinances
relative to the expansion of outdoor
dining and i can share with the
committee our experience at the
municipal association when this
emergency order came out the emergency
order that that put this language first
out there there was a fair amount of
confusion about what that meant the
shared spaces expansion um and the local
approval process and we worked with the
attorney general's office to help advise
municipalities that that was meant to
mean
that local rules and regulations still
apply in the expansion process but the
subcommittee does have an opportunity
here to
make that language a little bit clearer
our other concern would be that the
language may create ambiguity with
regard to the applicability of building
codes fire codes potentially other
safety or health codes for example the
original merge emergency order from
where this language comes had language
in it about the safe use of tents for
outdoor seating and that language is is
not found
in this bill so i think there is an
opportunity here for that language to be
fleshed out a little bit and made
clearer
there was also a question earlier i
believe from representative fellows
about the section on construction
municipal construction
in during the the state of emergency and
the question was whether that section
was still needed or whether cities and
towns have gotten back to their normal
practices with issuing building permits
and going through those processes our
information and observation is that most
things like that have returned to normal
so the section may not be necessary but
i also don't see it as doing any harm if
it's included in the legislation so that
concludes my testimony on the bill
itself i'm happy to take any questions
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
represent goalie
thank you madam chair and just reading
this briefly i have one quick question
on how a
city or town
uh
defines us on page eight
lines
eight and nine the outdoor dining area
shall be clearly delineated and
distanced from the public
can you tell me how you distance from
the public when you're allowed to be on
a sidewalk or a street
that is language in the
the way i understand that language is
that's part of the permission that the
state is giving if the
uh dining establishment is able to meet
those standards those are not
municipal regulations or standards those
are requirements that the state is
putting on the outdoor dining
establishment to meet so
local rules and regulations don't
necessarily use that same language
that's language in the bill that the
state is basically telling the food
service establishment or restaurant they
need to meet in order to be able to
permanently expand their outdoor dining
but to your point
there are
many terms in this part of the bill that
aren't defined and are not clear like
that they are allowed to expand
permanently if it can be done safely and
what the word safely means is not
defined and could be
subjective to the person you know
approving it if there's no definition of
the term
so that's another issue that i would
suggest the subcommittee um might want
to look at here as well as as terms like
the ones you're bringing up that are not
defined
thank you i agree with that
right represent o'brien
thank you madam chairman uh
my question would be also that you would
like probably to see included not to put
words in your mouth but uh i don't see
anything in this as far as ada
compliance and the example of the city
of nashville we have put ramps in
off the sidewalk down to the uh
associated dining area so that uh
handicapped friends can enjoy the
outdoor dining and not have the barrier
of a carving
okay that's an excellent point
representative o'brien municipalities
have an obligation to comply with the
americans with disabilities act and that
actually includes access to public
spaces like sidewalks they have an
obligation to do their part to make
sidewalks accessible to all individuals
including individuals who use
wheelchairs or have other disabilities
um that that you know the sidewalk needs
to be maintained in a certain way and so
this goes back to sort of the relatively
ambiguous language about being subject
to local approval if it's on a quote
shared space that has been for this the
duration of the state of emergency and
this order being in effect via emergency
order that has been routinely um
interpreted to mean that municipalities
can put those regulations or or can put
those requirements on restaurants as
they expand to comply with certain rules
about the ada to comply with rules about
sidewalks use of the street obstruction
in roadways but the language could
absolutely be clearer and as we all
remember from as things were unfolding
during the pandemic
issues were being dealt with very very
quickly and ends were needed very very
rapidly but to the extent that this
committee wishes to to pass legislation
to continue to extend outdoor dining
there's a real opportunity here to fix
some of the language um and and to make
it better if it's going to be
at you and extended longer
i'll follow up if i may follow up
uh thank you madam chairman uh
such as in the case of nashua i'm on the
infrastructure committee when we put the
barriers up because we do take one lane
of main street we made sure that they
were jersey barriers for the public
safety do you think that's something
that needs to be taken into account when
you're accessing a public way or
local
common sense would apply to the
municipality to do such
i think that our municipality are well
equipped to make those decisions about
what is needed to make outdoor dining
safe and that is exactly the kind of
considerations they need to make if a
restaurant is going to expand partially
into the roadway i've seen it in nashua
i've seen it in concord they're expanded
out into what would normally be a
parking spot out into the road the city
or town needs to be able to come to the
restaurant owner and say we need
barriers we need you know these
particular steps to be taken to keep
safe both the traveling public and the
dining public um and that's why it's
important that those local rules still
be in place even if this legislation is
passed
thank you miss burns for taking my
questions thank you madam chair
representative fellows
thank you madam chair um ms burns thank
you for bringing up
um the
concern about this sentence
about shared space where it says
coordinate and seek approval from
local authorities as i was confused
about
that because of its ambiguity and i'm
hoping that the intent is that they will
need to obtain approval from the local
authorities
but my um question
is
do you think
that this section
about expanding this the seating into
the outdoor could
run into an issue with
for example a restaurant with a lot of
land outside it could put in
many more
tables than their indoor capacity
is even when full seating is allowed and
that that would that run into some
local ordinances and
approval for occupancy and that sort of
thing that municipalities would be
concerned about
that's a great question i think those
are
those are potentially the types of
issues that municipalities look at when
expansions of use expansion of business
expansion of a building is
is done is they look at those particular
types of issues and they are
the the properly situated entity to look
at that and make decisions about um what
is safe and what should be permitted in
in their community so the example you
give is is very specific so i can't
really comment on on that specifically
but certainly issues with occupancy and
we heard earlier about issues with you
know water and sewer
load on buildings as well we heard those
comments and and i think what is um so
sort of amazing about this sort of thing
is the amount of impacts that a simple
expansion can have
it can be hard to to sort of anticipate
all of that um but municipalities are
there at the ground level looking at
these issues and making sure that the
expansion is being done um safely and
it's taking into account sort of all the
moving parts that go into expanding the
size of a building or expanding a
business and and the impact it has on
the community as well as on the business
so i think it's an another good example
of of me
potentially a local issue that could
come out of this
yes um thank you for your response and i
also want to thank mr tardiff for
bringing up his issue
thank you
other questions oh excuse me
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so miss burns uh
thank you very much uh you're this is
obviously as you're aware a fluid and
situation that's also in flux so uh my
question is whether
you're going to be available for the
subcommittee
yes absolutely and i understand that the
subcommittee meeting is tomorrow if i
have that correct but whenever it is i
am um i am available to assist in any
way i can i don't believe the
subcommittee has yet been scheduled
sorry i misheard that sorry madam chair
it's a different subcommittee tomorrow
understood
thank you yes i wanted to uh ask the
same question
that said that representative schmidt
asked because i did i did find that
uh the local issues that are good that
that each town has and that they are
familiar with handling should have the
um the flexibility that they need should
be in this bill so i'm very pleased and
i i wanted to know if miss burns and mr
cardiff would be available for the
subcommittee meeting because i do
believe that it's going to
representative roy's subcommittee who i
see as his hands up and i'm a member of
that
okay
representative roy
thank you
thank you for taking my question
um when looking at this
i'm trying to
find a way to match the intent of the
law
with
the the various hurdles that
we're hearing
and
at the end of the day it sounds like the
law would be kind of pointless because
at the end of the day we're suggesting
that it has to go through all the things
that it currently would have to go
through so is there any way
that in your
view from your
association's view that this law could
pass and still have the
intent of enabling this outdoor dining
without
doing it exactly as if this law had
never passed
that's a great question and what i would
say about the intent and i i think i
referenced this earlier what i would say
about the intent is
when when this language was put into an
emergency order back in whenever it was
last spring last summer
we understood and we have been operating
with our municipal members under the
understanding
that
even the emergency order was meant to
continue to allow a local role
in the process of expanding outdoor
dining so
i think there is still an ability to
have this statute be meaningful while
allowing municipalities to exercise the
not only the authority but also the
responsibility they have so a meaningful
way to make it clear that their
authority with regard to regulating
streets
parking sidewalks um things of that
nature still all stay intact i think
it's possible to do that and i would
also say and i'm certainly not an expert
in this area but when i look at the
language of the the statute it does
reference licensure under a separate
state scheme right i believe it's 148-a
so i believe the other intent perhaps of
this statutory change is to
impact the state licensing scheme which
would not be a municipal um a municipal
issue so there's i think that intent
going on here as well with this part of
the bill
follow up follow up
thank you
okay so as the
chair of the subcommittee i would just
say that i'm coming to it with a blank
slate i'm ambiguous either way
but
i want to look at what the intent of the
drafters was and i i want to also i'm
hearing a lot of issues i'm hearing
septic issues i'm hearing zoning issues
fire issues so please take and if you
can let me know if you're able to
prepare um
both ways
a solution that the association will be
comfortable with instead of just all
because i think we've heard all these
things can you can you get something
like that together
i certainly can try yes i can try to put
something together that will address
exactly the the point you're making yes
thank you i appreciate it
okay are there other questions from the
committee
mr aidan moore
today excuse me good afternoon madam
chair
uh can you hear me
yes please introduce yourself
yes thank you my name is aiden moore i'm
the legal coordinator for the state
liquor commission
and
i wanted to
[Music]
certainly make myself available to the
subcommittee
on those issues i also wanted to point
out to the
committee members
that
in existence
currently is a statute rsa 178
colon 24
and rsa 178 24
was recently amended in 2018
and expanded
and this is the vehicle
that the commission uses
to allow a licensee to extend the
service of alcohol
outside of the four walls of their
licensed business
and as a part of this
this provision
allows the business to come to the
commission
and present plans and diagrams etc
and that the petition
must conform to local zoning
requirements
including written reports from local
officials
who um i think as ms burns testified to
were had a variety of issues on health
and fire and access and things of that
nature
and that the commission um has the
ability
in its discretion to deny a petition
under this section
if they see a risk to health safety or
welfare to the community
now i think in senate bill 155
some of this is
is duplicated
um
and
without spending too much time it does
promulgate the commission it does tell
the commission under
uh section four that it needs to
um revise its administrative rules under
liquor rule 404.04
and uh
with the concerns that exist as i've
i've been listening to the testimony
i think
if this provision is to
uh it needs to be harmonized i guess
would would probably be the best way for
me to describe it with the existing
provisions of 178.24
and it may very well be that after the
subcommittee
takes up this matter and reviews 178.24
it may determine that um maybe this bill
is duplicative um but i certainly wanted
to make the committee aware of the
statute 178.24 and to make myself
available to the subcommittee
in their work on this particular piece
of legislation
thank you very much for that offer we'll
be taking you up on it
uh what
are there any other questions for mr
moore
i don't see any
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
on senate bill 155 and not the amendment
mr tardis
hi uh thank you again uh madam chairs
just wanted to say that i would be happy
to and uh and welcome the opportunity to
attend and sit in on the subcommittee
meetings
thank you we'll
expect that
thank you
people
wishing to testify on the basic bill
seeing none we will move on to amendment
and i call the sponsor representative
baxter
madam chair can you hear me
yes
thank you madam chair i'm a
representative from district rockingham
20 representing seabrook and hampton
falls and this amendment to sb 155 which
is 2021-1149-h
would prohibit the state of new
hampshire in any of its political
subdivisions from mandating the covet 19
vaccine vaccine passport or any other
immunity documentation or discrimination
against anyone for not receiving the
covet 19 vaccine in addition this
amendment prohibits the state of new
hampshire from entering into any
contract
or distributing any taxpayer money to
any private business that requires a
covid 19 kobe 19 vaccine passport or
immunity documentation of its employees
or patrons or in any way discriminates
against an employee or patron for the
refusal to receive a covet 19 vaccine
vaccine passports could discriminate
against people flying traveling trying
to get a job or even something as simple
as going to the supermarket many are
concerned about the disproportionate
impacts as something as simple as
requiring an id for things like voting
this would have an even more
disproportionate impact on those sane
marginalized communities imagine the
impact that a vaccine passport could
have on these communities as we slowly
move out of the covet 19 pandemic we can
be a society that values freedom or we
can be a society that segregates people
into groups and then discriminates
against one of these groups because they
make different medical choices than the
other group
arguably the primary purpose of
government is to protect the rights of
its people one of the most fundamental
rights is the right to bodily autonomy
medical decisions need to be discussion
between people and their doctors not
politicians and ceos
vaccine passports are also a gross
violation of medical privacy new
hampshire state constitution part 1
article 2b states an individual's right
to live free from government intrusion
in private or personal information is
natural inherent and essential any moves
from government to mandate the tracking
of the covid19 vaccine recipients would
be a violation of this section of the
constitution and this amendment serves
to strengthen the resolve of this state
to protect the privacy of its citizens
from government intrusion but also
serves to make a statement to the
private sector that taxpayer money will
not be used to support violations of
medical privacy or infringement of the
right to bodily autonomy in conclusion
vaccine passports are a violation of
medical privacy and are also a violation
of our bodily autonomy vaccine passports
could lead to widespread discrimination
especially against marginalized groups
i urge everyone on the committee to
support the amendment 2021-1149-h
to protect the individual right to my
body my choice thank you madam chair
thank you are you available for
questions
yes i am
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question i'm not aware of any
mandatory vaccine orders or any vaccine
passports
the what i received when i got my
vaccine it was just a card is i
other than political rhetoric is this
even a thing that we need to be worried
about
thank you representative for your
question this is a preemptive measure
to prevent something like a vaccine
passport that businesses or government
agencies could put forward in the future
uh unh is putting forward the vaccine
mandate so that would be one example but
this is a preventive preventive measure
to prevent the types of discrimination
that i was talking about above thank you
for your question
follow up madam chair follow up
uh
thanks for the reminder on unh so would
the way that your amendment is written
bar unh from setting uh rules like that
which would be
intended only to keep their students
safe
so yes this would bar unh from having a
vaccine passport because
this bill prevents any um
government agency or private business
that receives taxpayer fund and unh
would fall into that category even
though they're not a business
i guess they're a non-profit but any
non-profit that receives government fund
as well would be barred from mandating a
vaccine passport on their employees or
their customers um and i would just to
your point about the intention of
keeping
their students safe
and i think the there's some other
people that are going to testify to this
as well but there's debate about whether
mandates actually lead to higher
vaccination rates and whether they
actually may cause a lack of public
trust and therefore less people to get
the vaccine so i think in my opinion
it's very much in debate as well
representative
uh madame chair follow-up
um representative schultz
you may follow up with a question but
you are not to debate the witness please
fair enough um i'm just confused because
you use the term vaccine passport when
previously you were speaking about
mandating vaccines
again i don't think anyone's talking
about vaccine passports in new hampshire
and but the mandate for vaccination
you're saying your
amendment is written in a way that the
intent would be
to
prohibit unh which is a state agency to
not
use not be able to require
vaccines of their students
correct
thank you for your question
representative
uh this would deal with both mandates
and vaccine passports
and that's preemptive preemptive in that
sense that if a government agency or a
business or non-profit was going to
start to require vaccine passport unh is
requiring a vaccine to attend graduation
so i do think that's a very real example
of sort of slipping down that slippery
slope
thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
representative
the language of your amendment
not only speaks of
vaccine passports but it also says any
documentation
so if a nursing home or hospital
is uh is keeping track of its employees
vaccination status or
their
rejection of vaccination
uh
how how are you going to keep from
prohibiting hospitals and nursing homes
from
protecting their patients
uh
with such languages any documentation
thank you representative for your
question so there is an exemption
in this piece of legislation or in this
amendment and i believe that exemption
deals with your concern
i know follow up madam chair it it
it it exempts hospitals does not exempt
nursing homes and there are
three or four of them that i could think
of in dover alone where i live and serve
uh so
it is that not a conflict
that's that is something that is due
since exempting hospitals is in the bill
the subcommittee should consider whether
or not they should also accept nursing
homes
okay
i was asking the representative
what's the specific question
the question well this is obviously
going to the nurse subcommittee are you
going to be available for the
subcommittee
i'm potentially available for the
subcommittee sure
okay thank you
very good
other other questions for representative
baxter
seeing none representative cushman
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee
my name is representative leah cushman i
am
a first term state rep for wear and
deering i am on the house health human
services and elderly affairs committee
um i'm testifying today in support of
this amendment
and
sorry just trying to pull it up thank
you um under the virtues of medical
ethics the patient right of
self-determination or bodily autonomy is
paramount
um physicians and nurses must respect
the medical decisions of every patient
understanding that they are individuals
with independent moral agency values
beliefs and culture
who all deserve the right to make their
own decisions without coercion in other
words my body my choice
for a doctor to deprive a patient this
fundamental human right would result in
disciplinary action by the medical board
malpractice lawsuits and potential loss
of their license to practice medicine
physicians and nurses like myself are
expected to ensure this right and also
must and so also must any places of
public accommodation
um so any place that's receiving
taxpayer money rather sorry in the area
era of covet 19 there is an increasing
tendency to marginalize and discriminate
against people who decline medical
treatments or devices such as
vaccinations or face coverings
this trend is reaching a pinnacle with
the advent of so-called vaccine
passports
may not be in a bill for new hampshire
this session but it is on the horizon
and it's being talked about
we are devolving from a nation that
protects the rights of its citizens to
have life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness to one in which rights are
only afforded to some based on their
private health information papers please
with increasing pressure from government
and media for businesses to require
customers to use uh a medical device
um or to receive a vaccination those who
decline are subjected to hardship by
having limited places to meet their
families needs allowing the development
of a two-tiered society in which those
who decline a medical intervention are
discriminated against is contrary to the
value of equality we value equality in
new hampshire and we guarantee equal
rights the right to an education in
public schools is not denied to any
children based on their vaccination
status
even doctors and nurses are allowed
exemptions from vaccines by employers
bodily autonomy applies to everyone
including patients in hospitals
including
staff in hospitals
your workplace should not require that
you
are forced to
take
a treatment or a medical product that
carries inherent risk
we can't allow this to continue expert
opinions change science is subject to
correction
but human rights must remain intact
private health information is private
it's up to us as a governing body to
stop this popul this propulsion toward a
technocratic society in which expert
opinion reigns supreme over basic human
rights
history shows us where we are headed
remember how jews were treated as
unclean in nazi germany remember how
black people were treated under jim crow
remember how hiv
patients were treated just as recently
as the 1980s
businesses and government must not be
permitted to create a medical caste
system therefore this amendment is
necessary to protect the rights of all
granite staters to maintain privacy over
their health information and ensure
they're not marginalized for exercise
exercising their right to
self-determination
thank you
questions for representative cushman
representative o'brien
uh thank you madam chair uh
representative cushman i'd like you to
put your nurses cap on
for this in particular
um
i understand what you're trying to do
here but do you see any other equal
overreach
such as if this amendment went through
uh a student entering into the school
system has to provide some documentation
of immunization do you see any overreach
into that area as a nurse do you see any
particular overreach into that area that
would stop a student from providing that
type of information
uh to get into school
uh i don't i don't know if overreach is
the term but there are exemptions for
vaccination requirements for schools in
new hampshire
we have religious exemption and we have
medical exemption so there are
you know um beliefs belief systems to
take into consideration people have the
right
um to act according to their conscience
and their truly and sincerely held
religious beliefs as well as
any medical excuse me medical
may prevent someone from getting a
vaccination
okay thank you for taking a question
thank you madam chair
representative allegro
no my question was answered well by uh
representative
thank you for taking my question are you
perhaps concerned that this amendment
under reaches in that everything is
called covet 19 and what do we do when
there's covet 20 and the north pole
variant and
these things perhaps won't be covered
and we'll have passports up for those in
the future
sure i think that you know we have a
dangerous precedent being set with the
way that government is reacting to covet
19 and businesses as well
um we're seeing kind of backpedaling on
advancements in medical ethics that we
that have occurred over the last 70
years
and i would i would definitely like to
see this expand to
um to any and all medical treatments or
vaccinations
thank you thank you representative
phillips
thank you madam chair
representative cushman you mentioned
that for students
they need to provide
proof of vaccinations to their schools
but there are exemptions for medical or
religious reasons so should we ever get
to the point where
there are passports would you be
okay with it if the pat if you could get
a passport saying you had a medical or a
religious exemption
and then passports would be okay
thank you for the question
i would not support
such
restrictive
exemptions to
having
you know to being able to carry out your
activities of daily life
um
i think that
even the requirements for schools
you know
any reason that someone objects to
vaccination whether it's conscientious
philosophical religious
um cultural
you know should all be valid reasons no
one should ever be forced
to take a medical treatment against
their will and no one should ever be
marginalized in society for for not
taking something
that they don't want to take
thank you
so follow us
yes one is fine
so
the passports um
they don't require the passport would
not be a requirement that somebody get
vaccinated
isn't that correct
representative fellows you're you're
trying to debate the
the witness i think that's that's
inappropriate
i'm sorry madam chair i was just trying
to get a clarification on exactly what
her position and any modifications might
be
thank you for the question um
madam chair if i may uh
please
thank you
um so you're correct it's that a vaccine
passport is not technically a mandate
but by placing
a a requirement for someone to have
something in order to participate in
various areas of society
you are coercing people into getting a
vaccine it's like a back door mandate
and many people because they wish to
participate in society like others
who don't you know many people who don't
want a vaccine but wish to participate
in society like they always have and
like everyone else has the right to
may give in because of these coercive
measures you know so it's a backdoor
mandate
thank you representative roy
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um we've discussed
with regard to um you know personal
autonomy
with with regard to these um
vaccinations and mandates and such but
could you speak a little bit to um the
privacy aspect to it so a question you
just got was
you know what if i had a
passport that
showed that i was exempt for religious
reasons wouldn't that in any event
reveal a private medical decision or
choice i had made to someone that was
not privy to it
represent cushman
i'm sorry the representative cut out can
you repeat the question representative
roy
yes um
you talked about
the
individual autonomy as far as making
medical decisions and not being forced
by the state but could you address the
privacy issue a question you got related
to passports
said well what if the passport said that
you were exempt isn't the fact you made
a choice to be exempt also a private
medical matter that that would be then
exposed
thank you for the question um yeah i
agree it is a privacy issue there are
only specific um
very uh
you know
what's the word yeah i guess just very
specific instances in society where that
people are privy to that information
and it's you know under ferpa for school
officials it's under hipaa for medical
professionals
um
it's not
there's no precedent and there this it's
never been
that anyone in society can ask you this
this private information about your
religious beliefs or your medical
history
thank you
other questions for representative
cushman
from the committee
seeing none
thank you representative cushman
and
i would call lisa english
is english
stop getting her shot doesn't seem to be
with us any longer she signed up to
speak
uh fine i'll call
representative harvey bollier
[Music]
hello um
thank you for my comments i'm just uh
calling in in support of the amendment
and i just wanted to make an additional
note that
i don't believe a passport uh should be
uh i think is a good idea because
uh how even having a vaccine passport
required in any case um
would mandate that somebody
has to
could you please introduce yourself and
repeat that last comment
okay
i'd like to mention to the people that
are here for the amendment on senate
bill 133
that it is not going to start at 2 30.
it is more i believe we can postpone it
until 3 30 based on the amount of number
of people who signed up to speak on this
bill
so
please take a break we will get we will
get to it today but
not for at least 45 minutes
thank you
represent harvey boglio
you're back could you uh introduce
yourself and finish your comments
okay i'm sorry um i don't know what you
heard but um just to reiterate i'm in
favor of the amendment
and i do not believe it is uh
appropriate to
require any sort of um
papers any sort of uh
visit to a to a medical facility
so and that that's
the main reason thank you that's all i
have to say
would you introduce yourself first
before you leave yes i'm i'm
representative julie at harvey bolia
representing the towns of tilton in san
bernardin
people who signed up
uh mr smith john schmidt
can you hear me
yes
yeah there's not much i can add to what
representatives back baxter and cushman
said but i'll just mention my own
personal feelings at this point
i will never get vaccinated
i don't believe in the germ theory of
disease i believe in the terrain theory
of disease so i don't believe
that we need vaccines to protect us from
so-called germs real or not
in this particular case with cov19 it's
highly questionable whether there is a
virus because no one's isolated it
but
so i don't want to be coerced into
getting one of these vaccine passports
and that's why i strongly support this
bill
and i feel that if you don't control
your own body you are a slave
thank you
mr schmidt
beth daily
to unmute yourself and speak to us
great well good afternoon madam chair
and members of the committee my name is
beth daley i'm the chief of the bureau
of infectious disease control at the
department of health and human services
i'm here to provide information on sb
155 fn as amended the department is not
taking a position on this bill but we
wanted to provide some accurate
information relative to section 9 which
is prohibiting coven 19 vaccination
requirements
as you all know immunization is
considered one of the most important
public health achievements of the last
century and they've prevented millions
of illnesses disabilities and deaths
here in the united states in new
hampshire
we have been providing the coven 19
vaccine now for five or so months and
the covid19 vaccine specifically has
already prevented millions of illnesses
thousands of deaths in the united states
and in new hampshire it has reduced our
covet 19 deaths by 92
since we introduced it which is really
great news
these coven 19 vaccines are authorized
for use by the fda they are not
investigational drugs clinical trial
data for all of these authorized and
recommended covit 19 vaccines were
carefully reviewed by the fda to make
sure that they are safe and effective
and there were no shortcuts taken
now because vaccination coverage is not
100 percent
nor are these vaccines 100 effective
there may be some settings where
implementing vaccine requirements are
going to be important and one example of
this is in healthcare settings many
healthcare facilities already require
certain employee vaccinations to protect
the lives of their most vulnerable
patients
one example of this is the influenza
vaccination
and this is an accepted part of working
in healthcare because first you want to
do no harm to your patients
we see that there is an exemption for
medical facilities in this proposed bill
but the language suggests that employers
are making the determination of what a
direct threat constitutes for themselves
which would lead
likely lead to inconsistent application
of the law throughout the state it also
opens the door for future restrictions
on immunization requirements and may
have other unintended consequences
for example there are laws in place
already that require certain vaccines
for children to enter school and these
laws are critical to public health and
they must not be jeopardized
this proposal is also problematic
because in order to comply with state
and federal kovid 19 requirements
employers and health care facilities
must take employee coven 19 vaccination
status into consideration for example
after an employee has been exposed to
coven 19 they do not need to quarantine
if they have been vaccinated however if
they have not been vaccinated that
employee does need to quarantine and
cannot go to work or school
under existing law people already have a
choice of whether to be vaccinated
unfortunately a person's individual
decision on whether to be vaccinated
puts others who are vulnerable at risk
and it makes sense that in some settings
such as health care we also have an
obligation to protect those vulnerable
persons
i also want to draw your attention to
the fact that there is another bill
circulating through the legislature
house bill 220 medical freedom and
immunizations
which provides for a very similar policy
proposal so if nothing else this
non-german amendment is unnecessary as
there is already another bill addressing
this topic
thank you for the opportunity to testify
and i'd be happy to answer any of your
questions
thank you
are there questions for miss daley
represent bailey
could you show me perks hold it up so i
could see it your smallpox passport or
your tuberculin negative tests or
thank you representative bailey i'm not
sure that's relevant
question
yes representative
yes thank you for taking my question uh
you cited some interesting statistics
but i would note that they're
strictly correlative
and uh
if you have a background in science you
know that correlation is not causation
so how do you know
that any change in the rate of infection
or in survivability
has anything to do with the
availability of a vaccine
well fortunately we have access to
patient-level information that's able to
make these determinations for us so if
you look at our long-term care facility
outbreaks which we were experiencing at
very high rates there were many many
over 100 long-term care facilities that
were impacted by coven 19.
and once we started vaccinating these
facilities these outbreaks stopped
occurring even though we were
experiencing significant community
transmission of cobit 19 so these were
really protected because they had such
great vaccination rates in those
settings and when you look at who's
dying right now in new hampshire it's
people who are not vaccinated
i wave the following it's okay thank you
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
hello dr bailey daley sorry uh i'm just
curious you mentioned another bill that
has
or the same tenants in it do you know
which committee that bill went to
yes it was in the hhs and elderly
affairs committee
thank you that seemed to me a more
logical place for this kind of issue
thank you
okay
other questions for miss daily
seeing none i call martin kohler
excuse me representative schmidt
thank you very much madam chair so dr
daley thank you very much for being with
us today um
this
committee hearing format is very
restrictive as you know questions and
answers
so the subcommittee that's going to be
held
will permit more of a dialogue to
eventuate will you be available for the
subcommittee
i will try to make myself a bill
available for that obviously my time is
quite limited as we're still responding
to the pandemic but i certainly will do
my best to contribute in some way
thank you or perhaps one of your subs
associates would be available one of
your colleagues
thank you
kaldorf
uh yes can you hear me
yes
so
thank you for having me my name is
martin koldov i'm a professor of
medicine at harvard medical school
and i've been doing vaccine research for
almost two decades
i'm a huge fan of vaccines and
i have two concerns about vaccines
passports
one is that
we have spent many decades trying to
promote vaccines and ensure vaccine
confidence and
for all vaccines
and by trying to do coercion that
limits the trust that is necessary for
vaccines
trust is a fundamental principle of
public health both that
the public trust public health
authorities but also that public health
authorities trust
the public
and by trying to do a coercion
that
may reduce the trust in vaccines and
vaccine confidence and not only for the
corporate vaccine but also for
other vaccines like influenza vaccine
and childhood vaccines like for measles
and polio and so on
so that is a major public health concern
with vaccine passports and vaccine
mandates that
it will reduce the confidence of
vaccines and i think we've already
started to see
that even just discussing mandates and
passports the other concern is that the
covet is a very uh
anybody can get caught with but the risk
of mortality the risk of death is 100
000 full difference between the oldest
and the youngest
so what's most critical is that we
vaccinate older people because they are
the ones who are at risk of dying
and
we still have a shortage of vaccines
less so in the u.s now but certainly
worldwide
so
if we mandate
vaccines for younger people who are
very limited risk for this disease and
less so than your influenza
that means that there's going to be less
vaccines available for older people both
in the united states but also very
importantly around the world for example
now there are huge outbreaks in india
and brazil and other countries and all
people there do not have the vaccines
available to them that they need
so that's a global issue but i think we
all need to think globally about these
things
so those are two public health reasons
why vaccine passports are not a good
idea
and while the intention is to reduce
mortality they might actually increase
mortality
and also affect the confidence in other
vaccines not only coffee vaccines so
thank you very much for letting me speak
thank you will you take a question
i'm happy to
very good representative schmidt
thank you very much madam chair so dr uh
your testimony is very interesting uh
but the the
amendment that we're looking at
not only
speaks of vaccine passports but it says
any documentation regarding vaccination
so uh are you saying that there should
be no record of people who are
who are getting the vaccine
on whatever basis
there should be no record of it and and
they should have no way of demonstrating
whether they have had a vaccine or not
uh no that's a good question certainly
not the vaccine records are important
both so that people know can remember if
they're vaccinated but also in the
healthcare setting
it's very important that they are in the
electronic health records that there are
records that a certain person was
vaccinated because that determines
whether they should be vaccinated later
on for example
so registering to have a registry
or vaccines or to have it in the health
records is a very important thing a very
good idea the problem is if there are
mandates
or passports that require people to be
vaccinated to for example go to
restaurants or attend the university and
so on
follow madam chair
thank you very much uh dr uh professor
uh so uh there's going to be a
subcommittee on this and would you be
available for the subcommittee because
this is an issue that is a very
uh complex with regard to how this would
be handled and your expertise would be
invaluable would you be available
uh if my if it's the schedule at the
time when i'm free then certainly yes
i'll be willing to talk to the
subcommittee
thank you so much representative roy
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um since you said
that you had been studying the subject
of vaccines and epidemiology for quite
some time
could you
tell me if you know
what the success rate or or how it's
turned out in countries around the world
that have mandated vaccines and mandated
vaccine documents
so for kovitz those are very limited now
so i don't want to speak to that because
i think there's not enough follow-up to
to determine that
there are certain vaccine requirements
for example for hospital personnel for
influenza vaccines
and there are certain requirements for
travel vaccines
but i think in general
there has never been proposed ever
the kind of vaccine passport eventually
mandates that
are being discussed currently around the
world
oh
follow up
i don't know if you heard me follow up
i did not hear the follow question no
i'm sorry
no representative roy are you hearing me
i don't know if he wants to do you hear
me now
i do so follow okay i'm sorry yes please
thank you
um thank you for taking one more
question
on that i'm aware that there are
countries that
leave it aside we can talk about
smallpox or percussives or other things
that mandate vaccines and i was
wondering if you had any insight into
whether that actually increased the rate
of vaccines in those countries or
whether it
what the if it had positive or negative
outcomes do you have any information on
that
i don't know uh of any country that uh
mandates uh this whole population to
have a vaccine
uh
uh domestically i'm not aware of that of
any such country the mantas i'm aware of
are specific to
to for example people working in
hospital
or there is mandates to travel to
certain countries in africa you need to
have a yellow
fever vaccine
you
any other questions for uh uh dr caldorf
okay see none thank you um
lori shreer
you cannot mute yourself and speak
thank you
for allowing me to speak
my name is lori schreier
i'm a resident of westmoreland new
hampshire
and i urge you to support the amendment
to sb 155 prohibiting state supported
discrimination of persons who do not
receive the covet vaccine
or provide proof of vaccination status
i urge you to take the action to protect
individual privacy liberty and freedom
in bodily integrity and medical
decisions for new hampshire citizens
myself and my husband and many other new
hampshire citizens that i know
are not ready or willing to be part of
an experimental medical trial for the
injections
currently only authorized for emergency
use for coven 19
with clinical safety and efficacy
trials
not scheduled for completion until 2023
with so many reports and possibly
unreported adverse reactions
no guarantee of efficacy and no
long-term studies for safety
any type of coercion to take the coven
19 injections would be unjust and
irresponsible at this time
every day there are news reports to the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
of serious adverse events injuries and
deaths occurring in close proximity to
these experimental shots
and new information keeps coming out for
example from israel which started
vaccinating earlier than most countries
indicating heart problems when younger
people are vaccinated furthermore there
is no documented proof that the shots
stop the spread
in fact is evidenced by more and more
breakthrough cases of covid coming to
light in fully vaccinated people it does
not serve us to instill the notion that
workplace and public spaces should
exclude unb vaccinated people to make
them safer
please support this amendment and
protect new hampshire citizens from
discrimination for choosing not to take
the experimental injections or showing
proof
of injection
also please take note of all the
references included in my written
testimony which i submitted yesterday
thank you
thank you ms schreier
will you take questions
i will
represent yeshua has one
thank you madam chair
um ms schreier you you mentioned uh
that you're waiting to hear uh results
of
tests and experiments and so forth if
all of those come back
validating the 90
efficacy rate that they are
um
producing right now would you then be
willing to take the vaccinations
well i will say that um that totally
depends on
the
efficacy of of the studies and also on
the adverse events that are starting to
be more and more reported
uh and the long-term studies
for 2023 is still not
as long as most vaccines have had and
this is not a normal vaccine
this is very different my understanding
from the definition of a medical vaccine
in history so i would not say
yes or no but i would
most likely be very very cautious to say
yes
thank you
other questions
in that case i call paula manahan
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
paula minahan state vice president state
government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals in the
state we're testifying only on the
amendment um as you stated earlier
and we don't have any concerns with the
underlying bill but we do have concerns
with section 9 of the amendment that is
being discussed
um while there is an exemption for
medical facilities on page two um lines
24 and 25
the language is very unclear to us and
dr daley kind of um
um
stated that and we agree um the direct
threat which is defined in on page 2
lines 20
to 30
do require an individualized assessment
of the individual's present ability to
safely perform the essential functions
of the job
that effectively means to us that all
hospital employees would need to be
individually assessed to determine if
the standard could be met
that would mean
since new hampshire hospitals employ
approximately 41 000 employees
that would be
a requirement that we believe is not
feasible and equates to an unfunded
mandate
hospitals care for sick patients
including those that are contr con have
contracted coven 19.
they must ensure that their staff their
patients and others that enter the
hospital are all safe the amendment does
not address public safety and or public
health which must be contemplated when
considering safeguards focused on
privacy related to the covid 19 pandemic
for these reasons we do not support
section 9 of the amendment
and i think representative schuett might
have suggested that um this be
contemplated or moved are
considered in hhs which as um dr daley
said um
house bill 220 and other bills related
to this topic were in um house hhs so
just um
just a thought and and um
house bill um
on 220 is currently in senate hhs um
with senator bradley's committee i'm
happy to um
answer any questions thank you for the
opportunity
oh excuse me can i just mention um a
colleague courtney tanner um does would
like to testify and i'm sure
representative maguire you allow for
others but um she um was not able to she
registered but did not hit
check the right box so if you would i
will we will
other people who wish to testify i
appreciate that thank you representative
very much and representative has a
question
yes madam chair um
the number you uh mentioned concerning
the number of employees that you'd have
to do individual assessments for
i mean would you actually have to do
that for all of them under this
amendment or only the ones that uh
uh you know chose not to get the vaccine
or not to provide any uh documentation
they'd had the vaccine
it
well
potentially depending on how this um was
worded if um if depending on again um
i'm just indicating that that's how many
employees potentially
um could would need to go through that
um
assessment i need to read it because the
exemption only
applies
where a direct threat exists
again i find the language and the
exemption very confusing um and so the
way i read it
and maybe i'm just mis
misinterpreting it
but you have to determine the direct
threat and the only way you determine
the direct threat
by definition
is if you if the individual it has to be
on an individual um poses a direct
the determination that an individual
poses a direct threat
so
i i'm not quite sure in order for the
hospitals to comply with this law
if passed
um it could potentially
require them to go through that process
for thousands of employees
that's just hospitals too um i think
there are others um other healthcare
facilities that may and and providers
testifying today or have have um
indicated their concerns
um we're just representing hospitals but
long-term care facilities and others
other physician offices could be in this
um also impacted
thank you
thank you madam chair
so paula uh
would it not also be the case i know you
represent the hospitals but wouldn't
wouldn't this bill have passed in this
form
would it not also implicate essentially
every doctor's office
and all their employees
as well
um
yes i again i think the exemption is
limited it does not define medical
facility sorry i just lost the paper ah
does not define medical facility
typically these bills when you define a
medical um
health care it's usually a health care
facility and it's usually under rsa 151
which is where
hospitals and long-term care
home care a number of facilities
are
licensed
as you i think as you know because your
edna um
doctors offices do not fall under a
health facility license they fall under
the board of medicine
um but
if the intent was to um address all
medical providers and facilities
yes it would also
impact the doctors
as well as community health centers
community mental health centers
the list could go on
follow up madam chair
one
thank you so yeah
i am the chairman of the stratfor county
delegation and have intimate contact
with an uh with our
riverside rest home which uh takes care
of about 200 people
uh
isn't it the case that there's a fair
amount of interaction between nursing
homes which i understand you don't
recognize i just represent uh but
nursing home patients frequently go to
the hospital and come back would it not
also implicate nursing homes and all
their staff and and uh
and
would they not also be involved with the
language of this amendment
oh absolutely yes um they are also
licensed under health facilities and
you're right i don't represent them but
yes um they go back and forth um
frequently when they need medical
services they will be transported to the
hospital and um
or if they have to be admitted to the
hospital so yes i believe that they
would be included thank you
representative
thank you madam chair thank you paul
other questions for ms manahan
all right thank you
thank you representative
laura condon
[Music]
good afternoon
good afternoon afternoon yes we hear you
please introduce yourself and
certainly my name is laura condon i live
in bedford and i am a volunteer new
hampshire director of advocacy with the
national vaccine information center and
as such i'm off on a contact point from
various members of the the public
parents legislators medias when it comes
to regard to vaccines
it's hard to follow the presentation of
representative baxter and representative
cushman here in presenting this bill i
think they are
made tremendous presentations um
representing that this bill is timely
inappropriate and is needed um
to protect the public against um vaccine
mandates that we're now seeing beginning
to occur at unh and other places
i should mention uh and make a
correction here
um to to what beth daley testified
these coveted shots are not fda licensed
they are as a distinction they are
allowed to be used under emergency use
authorization only
there is a very
scientific and legal distinction between
those two processes and i think that
the public should be aware of that that
these vaccines have not been
fully evaluated for safety and advocacy
there was also she also mentioned about
um
representative there was a decline in
deaths i actually work for the insurance
industry and last week we had an
actuarial presentation we were looking
into how covet impacted life insurers
and health insurers
it was noted that there has been about a
ten percent increase
in deaths for for life insurers
not not an increase that the industry
couldn't handle that's certainly
manageable
and
it is not unlike the increase that the
life insurance industry will often see
in a bad flu
season
so this has been seen before
what these type of death increases often
see in a subsequent year as a
significant decline in deaths as the
most frail and the most elderly have
died in the previous year
bring any vaccine in the market
cannot claim credit for that natural
decline in deaths because there are less
alleluian frail people so it's a
misrepresentation
miss condon
yes this is fascinating but if you could
concentrate your testimony on the bill
in front of us or the amendment in front
of us
okay the point is that
coralization correlation is not
causation
when claiming benefits of these vaccines
i believe that
it is important to protect against
vaccine mandates and the passports
the um vaccine adverse event reporting
system that the cdc relies on has
already recorded 486 adverse events in
new hampshire from these coveted shots
and 33 deaths
we are also seeing coveted vaccines um
experience failure
um dhhs has reported already 24 cases
and two deaths from covid following
vaccination and they're expecting more
some of these vaccines are quite
hazardous in fact we've all seen that
the jansen vax was suspended their use
was suspended because of blood clots and
deaths
the advisory committee and immunization
practices voted last friday to allow
this vaccine this particular coveted
shot back on the market but it was a
split decision ten to four the four
dissenting mentors were
terribly distressed that it would be
allowed back on the market without
disclosing and warning the public of the
hazards that they are made aware of
the direct threat language here
mentioned in the bill is an equal
opportunity
employment provision and um provisions
of the ada and civil rights protections
that hospitals cannot force vaccines
without making any accommodations
and i think um given all these concerns
this amendment that would allow
protection against vaccine mandates and
again events
against vaccine passports is timely and
needed so i i do urge you to support it
thank you
thank you are there questions from miss
panda
all right see done thank you very much
for your testimony
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify who hasn't yet
ah okay there's some people coming up
let me bring you in
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee
i'm gina balkas and i'm the ceo of the
granite state home health and hospice
association
which advocates on behalf
of home care hospice and palliative care
providers and the people they serve
our organization opposes section 10 of
this amendment which would create
chapter 9g
as it relates to covet vaccinate
vaccination status and documentation
first
it's important to know that home care
and hospice providers care for many of
our most vulnerable citizens in their
own homes
and the safety of our staff and our
patients is our highest priority
home care and hospice agencies have
encouraged staff to receive coveted
vaccines
but we respect the rights of those who
choose not to be vaccinated
i am unaware of any association members
that are mandating covert vaccines for
their staff
but this amendment would prevent
providers from requesting vaccination
status from their staff
and it's important to know that it's
essential that agencies know which of
our staff have been vaccinated and which
have not
as their status may impact which
patients they are assigned to care for
patients who have certain medical
conditions
are severely immunocompromised
or who themselves are unable to be
vaccinated are at higher risk of
contracting covet 19.
so agencies may choose to adopt special
ppe protocols for unvaccinated staff
that's not discrimination
that's good medical practice
in addition
in home care and hospice because
these staff are going into people's
homes
patients can decline services from
specific staff
so i will tell you that in the past
couple weeks i have heard from agencies
who are getting requests from patients
to only send vaccinated staff to their
home
and so agencies have to do their best to
honor these patient
requests the direct threat clause on
page 2 line 20
uh and the medical exemption
that applies to medical facilities
we believe that the medical so home care
and hospice agencies are defined as
health care facilities under rsa 151
but the direct threat clause is really
unworkable because as ms minihan stated
it would require a health care provider
to evaluate each employee's potential
threat to patients
and home care and hospice agencies need
to be able to adopt policies that apply
consistently to all unvaccinated staff
and not be required by law to assess
each unvaccinated employee
so i respectfully request that you find
amendment 1149h as inexpedient to
legislate
thank you for the opportunity to speak
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you are there questions
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
good afternoon miss balkas so
you raised one of the issues that we had
not explored up to this point and that
is
this home care situation
uh can you give us a rough estimate of
how many people are in home care in new
hampshire
and and also how many people
are
providing that care
so the average daily census in
home care agencies at least among my
members and we have 46 43 agencies that
are members is about 10 000 patients on
on any given day
um i don't have handy
how many uh employees there are
um but it's well over ten thousand in
order to care for these staff for these
patients
all right follow up madam chair
so if these staff are going from house
to house
uh providing home care
uh they are
incredibly
uh vulnerable are they not to uh
infection if they're not protected in
some fashion
uh yes the uh they are um
vulnerable as are their patients
and so that's why during the pandemic uh
ppe was of the you know protective
gear was the utmost importance
and um
and why we're all so thankful for the
vaccine but as i mentioned
it we totally respect the right of staff
who choose not to get the vaccine but we
need to be able to know who they are
in case um
accommodations need to be made
one more follow-up madam chair
one more
thank you
um so the thing is that to the degree
that you have
patients and staff interacting with lots
of people
they're not only vulnerable but they're
also potential vectors
and
[Music]
dr daly in her testimony
i talked about the degree of uh
effectiveness efficacy in other words of
the vaccines in the nursing homes which
was contradicted by misconduct testimony
so uh i believe that dr diddy was
talking about not
uh
not
preventing
um
deaths which is what miss kanye was
talking about
representatives yes mike i'm answering
i'm asking my question madam chair not
everything can be said in two words
uh so it to the degree that uh that the
people
um
are being vaccinated
now that there's a vaccine
uh
is it not the case that you're having
fewer infections as a result in your
experience with your clients
you know i really don't have that level
of data representative schmidt to be
able to answer that question
okay would you be available to the
subcommittee
i will do my best to be available to the
thank you much
other questions
in that case uh lilly williams
and
can you hear me
yes we can hear you thank you thank you
man introduce yourself and please don't
take the 10 minutes you asked for i know
i know i just did not know i'm kind of
new here so
and my name is uh liddy tong williams i
moved here 18 months ago from colorado
and living where i'm here to represent
myself to strongly support
this amendment
i i was born and grew up in communist
china as a little child well lined up in
government schools without parent
consent all choices were lined up and
little dots and to get all vaccines that
the government wanted us to do
and then we were trapped by household
registration system
a national id with a booklet you have no
privacy at all and in schools then we
have
a student file then document everything
about you so we were not treated really
like a human being supposed to have a
little bit privacy zero privacy i mean
they could basically come to your home
to sit on your bed and talk to you
so i come to this country when i was
about 24 years old i just was desperate
to get out of china because i feel like
my life there
was not really worth living it was like
a little good little slave and if you do
something they want to say behave their
way they want you to behave you're okay
you have okay life but otherwise you
can't get locked up and you can
disappear i had a little bit brain and
intelligence left i was planning to
leave for a new country called america
but i had to get a
permission to even go apply for my
passport and i had to you know plan my
political strategy to say the things
they want me say in order to get the
passport so now here we are in this
country many years later i am american
citizen i'm really worried about the
trend that our government is going down
our country is going down
it's really not good i'm very terrified
worried for our country especially last
year when this china wuhan virus come to
the world come to this country i saw how
our civil liberties all just went down
the drain the free america i had in mind
for the sake of public health and
security we were supposed to obey
everything that the government wants us
to do and shut down business and wear
masking getting vaccine and do i have a
choice if what if i don't want to get a
vaccine what if i don't want to carry
another similar some kind of id card to
track me make me have no privacy as a
american citizen in this country
i don't want relief in china
i love this state
i believe you our model
live free or die
remember our founding father said if you
give up you liberty for security you
will end up to be have neither
i have been warning people for years
about this country is going down this
bad path dangerous path more
totalitarian more bigger government more
big tech corporations more everything to
control individual citizens like me
i am smallest minority on earth
i am a chinese immigrant who knows what
it's like to live without freedom
without privacy and you're not treated
like a human being either without
dignity without pride
without anything
might just be like a little animal right
i object to mandatory vaccine
requirement
i reject
passports that will be like china's
social credit system put a little code
on your cell phone and track you
everywhere you go
like today's chinese
24 hours a day
and you will have no privacy and then
you have no civil society you will have
a slow civil liberties
this is not even partisan issue
so i want you to hear my personal story
my personal experience under a total
totalitarian country
and
i appreciate your time and i will be
waiting to talk to anybody about this
and i'll be willing to go to your
subcommittee and i'm trying to get my
stories message out to save my new
country
thank you for your time
thank you miss williams are there any
questions
i don't see any
so thank you again
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
on the amendment to senate bill 155
someone
good afternoon madam chair my name is
courtney tanner and i'm the director of
government relations at dartmouth
hitchcock
yes please
thank you for the opportunity to testify
i'd like to focus my testimony today on
the amendment specifically section nine
we have serious concerns about this
amendment our mission and our primary
responsibility is to the to provide
quality care in a safe environment
hospitals and healthcare facilities
employ a variety of strategies in order
to ensure
a safe environment and one of those
elements of the safe environment is a
healthy workforce as paul manahan
pointed out we have significant concerns
about the exemption
as
as provided in the amendment
implementing this exemption would
be more than an administrative burden
for us we really see it as near
impossible for the reasons that beth
daly pointed to also
dartmouth hitchcock
health employs over 13 000 employees
it's our responsibility to ensure that
all of our employees are healthy and
prepared to serve our patients across
the entire state
we want to highlight that that we do
have religious and medical exemptions
available to our employees for our
annual influenza program these
exemptions are working
um
we finally i just would like to note
that senator bradley highlighted that we
are navigating severe workforce
challenges when he introduced the the
original bill senate bill 155
we don't have the ability to simply move
staff around and refute who refuse
vaccination so we we are
significantly concerns about the
implications if this amendment were to
pass
we believe that this amendment would
significantly impact our ability to
staff our hospitals and would therefore
impact patient care and access to care
we strongly urge this committee to
oppose um
section 9 of this proposed amendment i'm
happy to take any questions
thank you are there any questions from
the committee representative allegra
thank you and thank you ms tanner for
taking my question
of course i'm going to guess but please
answer my my first question then i'll
answer follow-up did you just hear miss
tang's uh testimony
i did have the opportunity to hear her
testimony great uh how would you address
that
uh how would you address her experience
that you described allegro that is also
fascinating but i'm not sure it's
relevant to the question okay well i'll
ask uh another question if i may please
um so we've heard plenty of testimony of
today of those who would prefer to not
receive the vaccination
another testimony of many thousands who
might not so my question is
is there any reticence at all
about forcing so many thousands of
citizens
to be injected with an entirely new form
of medication and then force them to
produce papers upon the insistence
of the government or other private
citizens
how i would respond to that is that we
we do roll out an annual influencer
program currently at dartmouth-hitchcock
health and we do have our employees do
have the ability to seek religious and
medical exemptions so
we're certainly not forcing any
vaccinations and the exemptions that we
have available to our employees are
working well follow up please
follow up once that's a question that
describes current policy but the policy
in the future that this uh
amendment seeks to
um protect against is different
so i ask again do you have
any reticence about forcing so many
thousands of people to
take a new medication that they prefer
not to
i think that don't think that's an
appropriate question okay thank you
sorry thank you representative
before representative schmidt asked this
question ms tanner would you be able to
support the subcommittee
yes i'm happy to make myself available
thank you representative spent
you already asked my question madam
chair
thank you
all right any other questions for miss
tanner
i've seen none i call harrington
and kochik
for something similar in kasich that's
close enough thank you madam chairman
for allowing me to testify most of the
points that i wanted to make
have already been made
right and and i'm not
i'm not here to be a proponent of
vaccinations or
or not i think it's taking a vaccine
of any type is a personal choice and uh
people can do what they need to do there
but
the the the concept of having a
requirement to have paperwork of some
kind
to show that you have had a vaccine
in order to
live a normal life
it to me is just absolutely foreign and
wrong and it's i mean i really resonated
with uh lilly williams testimony a
couple of people ago
citizens should not have to give up
personal freedoms to live a normal life
and it was mentioned earlier that doing
this grants special privileges to a
certain population while limiting others
access
so i'm not even going to go into the
medical concerns that i have on this but
i'm going to come at it from
a constitutional perspective
to to me
this is
a an issue because it says you have to
have a vaccine some people
like myself
have had covet and so we have natural
antibodies
right so why would i need to get a
vaccine
i i i don't believe i need one uh given
that i've had covered which by the way
amounted to three days of mild cold
symptoms for me
texas and florida have already passed
similar legislation to what we're
talking about here in this amendment
and and it's been ruled at as
unconstitutional at the federal level
you know so despite the fact that it's
being talked about there uh it looks
like it's not gonna happen as a
nationwide mandate
uh this this particular amendment by the
way and reading through it it addresses
uh entities that
uh benefit from state funding in some
way my belief is that this amendment
needs to be amended so that it expands
it to all entities public and private
businesses
most of you i'm sure are uh familiar
with with rsa what is it 354-a
colon 16
right which um which which basically it
well does it basically it says equal
access to public accommodations is a
civil right
one one of the uh reasons there is is is
your creed
and others have mentioned exemptions for
religious
and medical reasons right but to do what
we're talking about doing with any sort
of documentation
confirming that you've had a vaccination
is in violation of existing state law
i think this bill
this amendment should be expanded to all
entities
um
there's a quote here that i thought was
interesting that i'll close with
uh by franklin delano roosevelt one of
my heroes he said we too born to freedom
and believing in freedom are willing to
fight to maintain freedom we and all
others who believe as deeply as we do
would rather die on our feet than live
on our knees
and we're headed toward living on our
knees as literally so eloquently
described
i
ask that you find this legislation
uh ought to pass
thank you madam chairman
thank you could you introduce yourself
please
oh i'm sorry i neglected to do that yeah
i'm aaron pinkasic i live in hollis new
hampshire
thank you are there any questions from
mr and kasich perfect
all right seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you ma'am
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on the amendment to senate bill
yes
mr juved when you can uh
meet yourself and
introduce yourself
yes thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
dave giuve i'm a senior vice president
with the business and industry
association
[Music]
we are the statewide chamber of commerce
and
represent primarily
private sector for-profit businesses i'm
here
speaking in opposition to the bill i
apologize i may have been called earlier
but i was called away to a
different hearing but i'm glad i had the
opportunity to speak
we object to this
because
essentially it's the state inserting
itself into private sector businesses
and telling them what they can and
cannot do
in terms of ensuring a safe
uh and healthy workplace for their
employees
these types of
vaccine requirements are already common
in the health care industry for for the
influenza flu vaccine and employers
recognize that there are some people
that may
uh prefer not to be vaccinated for re
religious or or medical reasons and they
are exempted from this in fact i think
even employees
who may not want to take it for
any reason can can request an exemption
they will most likely be required to
wear masks but in today's environment
everyone's wearing a mask anyway
so my primary point is um please
resist the urge to tell private sector
employers
what they can and and cannot do to try
and ensure a safe workplace for their
employees and their customers and then i
know it was mentioned earlier but i want
to emphasize there's already a house
position
on this issue it's house bill 220 which
has passed the house
and
is now in the senate and it goes further
than this bill
it relates to all vaccines not just
coven 19 and it relates to all employers
not just those employers
that may have a contract with the state
so it it
seems somewhat senseless for me for for
this committee to be considering
this um
more limited
amendment when you've already passed a
bill there's already a house position on
this issue uh thank you madam chair i'd
be happy to answer any questions
thank you are there questions
i have one if you're opposed to the
amendment why are you
suggesting that house bill 220 is okay
uh we're opposed to house bill 222 madam
thank you
um i i was just
using that by way of let making sure the
committee understood that this issue has
already been addressed by the house
thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh uh good
afternoon mr gervais um
uh yeah i take it you've read the bill
quite closely
i've read the non-germane amendment
quite closely that's what that's that's
what i'm talking about
okay so uh follow up madam chair
so uh does it strike you that the that
the
the amendment that's what we're talking
about
is uh is quite comprehensive and would
effectively
uh impose these restrictions on
a great majority of new hampshire
businesses
well it uh thank you for the question
representative schmidt i i believe so i
i don't
have a sense of how many private sector
businesses contract with the state but i
suspect it could be in the thousands i
asked commissioner arlinghaus that
question and he also was unsure but
speculated that it was a thousand or
more so it is certainly a lot of private
sector employers
and follow up
so do you think the bill is workable in
terms of the
the
restrictions it would impose on
uh on the businesses that it would it
that it would impact
our fundamental objection to the
non-germain amendment
is that is the state inserting itself
into the private sector
and telling employers what they can and
cannot do
in terms of trying to maintain a safe
and healthy environment for their
employees and their customers i'm not
sure
how you go about fixing that unless it's
to remove the section relating to
private sector employers
thank you thank you
representative
thank you and uh thank you mr gervais
for taking my question does the state
insert itself into private business
matters in other fair areas
uh that's an excellent question
um
and in many
cases there are many examples with other
legislation i can think of that the bia
is also opposed for example we opposed a
mandatory requirement for paid family
leave we were certainly in favor of a
voluntary program we were opposed to
uh mandatory
uh payment for accrued but unused
vacation time and there are probably a
number of other areas where the state
has tried to tell private sector
businesses how to best run their
businesses and we are generally in
opposition to those
thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
and thank you mr gervais for taking my
question
as we know
these variants are becoming more
communicable
don't you think businesses have the
right
to protect their employees not only uh
just the employees themselves but also
their businesses
and uh we know at
isn't there evidence that once uh
one employee contracts uh covert 19 that
it could spread throughout the business
shutting down that business for
days and costing a loss of revenue for
that business thanks representative
goalie and it's nice seeing you again by
the way i miss not seeing you on the
labor committee uh yeah i think that is
a very real world concern that employers
have and i might add
that the bia supported legislation that
both the house and senate have decided
to
park or back burner relating to
establishing a legal safe harbor for
businesses who are doing the right thing
and complying with with federal and
state um health and safety guidelines
both chambers have decided that issue
needs more study
so businesses are are not only concerned
about what's in the best interest of
their employees and their customers but
they're also concerned about potentially
uh not being able to implement something
now and then end up being sued over it
thank you
are there other questions from the
committee
thank you for your testimony thank you
madam chair thank you members of the
committee
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on the amendment to senate bill
good afternoon again i'm margaret burns
with the new hampshire municipal
association nhma is opposed to the
non-germane amendment and to be clear we
do not have a position relative to
requiring vaccines but along the same
lines uh with of the testimony from the
bia we do oppose legislation that
supplants local authority and decision
making with state mandates and puts new
requirements on cities and towns section
10 of the amendment prohibits a
political subdivision not only from
requiring a person to receive a vaccine
or provide proof of a vaccine even more
concerning it would prohibit a political
subdivision from contracting with a
private business that requires vaccines
or proof of vaccines and then treats a
violation of that provision as a breach
of contract that would render the
contract voidable
this creates an interference with local
decisions and it's a burdensome
responsibility because as i read it it
would require municipalities to somehow
monitor the actions of private
businesses and employers with respect to
vaccines so that they could then take
that into consideration when deciding
whether they are able to enter into
various service contracts with private
vendors and businesses with respect to
the section on outdoor dining
i won't reiterate the concerns that i
expressed in the senate bill 155 hearing
they remain the same the language is
very very similar the only additional
thing i would say is that the amendment
obviously makes the extension of outdoor
dining permanent and it would seem more
prudent to go the route of senate bill
155 which does the extension through
2023 and allows there to be some kind of
assessment before that time period runs
out about whether it should be extended
further so we are opposed to the
non-germain amendment and that concludes
my testimony thank you
thank you are there any questions
all right team now thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on the amendment to senate bill
all right see none i will close the
hearing on senate bill 155 and its
amendment
and we will take up the
non-germain amendment to senate bill 133
in five minutes
and i would
respectfully request anyone who was here
just for 155 to leave the meeting
thank you
[Music]
yeah
it doesn't seem to be that old
[Music]
sorry
perhaps
okay
hi mary jane
representative wallner uh we're taking i
don't know if you've heard but we're
just taking a short
five minute break before we resume
thank you
my pleasure
it's unusual the video is one
mary jane
yes hi sally hi it's warm and sunny up
here
it's it's
sunny here i don't know if it's very
warm
but it is sunny it looks great outside
yeah it seems pretty nice
hello peter
i don't have my camera on but i guess
you recognize those dulcet tones
i did
we will resume as soon as our clerk gets
back
uh
five minute breaks number one
correct correct says
see
thank you all for coming welcome to edna
this is the hearing on
a non-german amendment to senate bill
133 and i call on representative walnut
thank you chair maguire and members of
the committee
i'm mary jane walner i'm a state
representative and i represent concord
ward 5 and hopkinton
the non-jermaine amendment number 1162
h
deals with the qualifications to be an
associate teacher in a child care
program
these three lines were in bill
house bill
that this committee retained earlier
this year house bill 230 dealt with
several areas of child care licensing
this amendment is very narrow and only
deals with one section of the bill
i am bringing this before you today for
your consideration because child care
programs are facing a crisis
and not being able to hire for vacant
positions
this amendment would just add
an additional pathway for people to
become employed in child care programs
as a as associate teachers
after house bill 230 was retained
i had several child care providers reach
out to me and ask me
what does it mean to have a bill
retained
those of us in the legislature of course
understand that language but to
the public it's not not quite so clear
and i explained to them that if the bill
would be dealt with
um later in the session and that we
would probably not
see the bill out
and becoming law until
a year from now
but the hiring crisis is now and child
care
programs need our assistance
i know you will hear from child care
licensing who will tell you they are
doing this now through waivers and this
will continue until the state of
emergency ends
but none of us know when that will be
but when it does end
child care providers will still need the
flexibility in hiring
will this solve all the problems in
hiring employees in child care
of course not
this just offers another pathway to
enter the field
the employment solutions for child care
are ongoing
and it will take a long-range plan and
lots of action to accomplish the kinds
of workforce we need in child care this
amendment is only a small piece to a
bigger puzzle but it will help in the
short term
with more and more fat people returning
to work child care
is an important support for both parents
and children
you will hear from child care programs
that because of the hiring crisis there
are programs closing
and many are not accepting the number of
children they cared for before the
pandemic
a shortage of child care
will provide barriers to many people
trying to return to work
an adequate supply of child care is an
important part of building a strong
economy this amendment
is one small piece in providing child
care that is needed by our new hampshire
families
i thank you for your consideration of
this amendment and i know this committee
has done a lot of work on child care
licensing and i appreciate all the work
you have done and i appreciate the
committee and the chair persons allowing
me to bring forth this amendment today
and i am open to questions
thank you margaret questions
representative lucas uh thank you madam
chair
um
i'm generally supportive of this idea
but i have a couple of questions just to
put it uh in context the first one is um
without this what are the current
requirements for someone like this to um
become licensed so you know current
requirements versus what this would put
in place
i believe the current i i no longer work
day every day in the child care field
even though i was a child care provider
for over 45 years
um but i believe currently
in the rules
you need
nine college credits
to be an associate teacher
though the um
[Music]
department the licensing
bureau did reach out to me and informing
that they are providing waivers to that
at this time
so something very similar
to
this amendment is happening now
uh by waiver and it will last
through
the
state of emergency
my
my thinking is that at the end of the
state of the emergency
it will still be
very difficult for child care programs
to
hire staff and that they will need they
will need this in place
for for the future
follow-up
okay the other question is um
this is uh being put in uh 178 170 11
which is rule making
and the other things in here tend to be
general areas that the commissioner
should adopt rules for
whereas this seems to be
setting up um you know sort of another
path for certification
and i don't know if remember off hand
just where that is in the rsas just
wondering why it ended up in this
section
um i was not the i i actually was not
the sponsor of the original bill um
house bill 230 and i only i took this
language directly from 230 so i think um
i'm hoping that representative williams
is here and she might be able to speak
to that
um
and it's not william
and she's the next person to speak okay
thank you
any
representative you had a question
thank you madam chair i will wait until
representative mcwilliam testifies
thank you
any other questions for representative
wallner
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
representative mcwilliams
thank you madam chair and members of the
edma committee
for the record my name is representative
rebecca williams excuse me could you
come closer to your microphone you're
extremely faint
let me turn up the volume too i
apologize
can you hear me now
i'm not
not 12.
i'm gonna have to weather through that's
as loud as it goes i'll speak loud
um so i'm
you're welcome uh i'm here to
speak very briefly in support of uh
adding this amendment to support child
care facilities and our
working parents and children who require
child care during the day
as representative walner mentioned
we're currently dealing with a staffing
crisis for child care facilities across
the state
um the problem is not the money i i know
we've heard this in previous testimony
in front of this committee that the
problem was the money the problem now is
not the money there are quite a bit of
federal funds that have been
specifically earmarked for child care
facilities for things like staffing and
ppe during this pandemic the problem
that we're running into the roadblock we
have right now
is this requirement of education for
associate teachers
and yes there is a waiver but it's still
a roadblock for advertising the position
and attempting to get people to
interview and be hired for these open
positions
so we're obviously seeing the ripple
effects of not having the staff that we
need for child care facilities this
means that
in working families one parent or in
some cases single parent families the
parent is having to choose between
staying home with the kids
or making life decisions that may alter
their career for the long term because
we can't support them
through child care in new hampshire so
it's a big deal we're at the pinch point
now
and so to address the question that was
addre that was asked to representative
walner
our issue really is because the omnibus
child care bill that i had sponsored
previously ended up being retained by
this committee
and we are in a pinch point we had to
find a senate bill that could
potentially be amended in order to carry
this forward
and so this is the bill that it was
added to so that's the the answer to the
question is this is the closest we could
find it's been amended and added
in in an effort to try to preserve and
save
as many staff as
industry right now
i'm happy to take questions
and actually representative mc williams
the question wasn't why senate bill 133
because it's
like you say it seems fairly appropriate
the question is why is this under rule
making
for um
rather than
specifically in the licensing for
uh
personnel
oh you mean the way that it's amending
the statute is that what you're getting
at i'm sorry i just need to clarify
um
if
it needs to go under licensing rather
than rulemaking it could be moved
but it still works under rulemaking
would be my response
represent representative blackis does
that answer your question
yes thank you representative
i don't i'm sorry man i'm sure i raised
my hand earlier when representative
walner was speaking but i'm um
representative mcwilliams answered my
original question and her testimony
thank you thank you very much are there
any other questions for representative
williams
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you madam chair
i call parent you all
you should
you can unmute yourself and speak to us
please
okay it takes me a while
okay can you hear me
yes please introduce yourself
okay um my name is karen jewell
and i am testifying um against senate
bill 133
i have a bachelor's degree in early
childhood education a master's in
educational leadership
and i studied the effects of poverty on
young children under bruce mallory
at the university of new hampshire's
doctoral program in education
i've directed child care centers in new
jersey massachusetts and new hampshire
many of which were nationally accredited
and most
serving low-income working families
during the 1990s i was new hampshire's
child care coordinator for the
department of health and human services
and also during that time i was one of
the one of 20 national
finalists
selected for head start scholars
as a former director of child care
centers i identify
totally with the directors
and others who support this bill
hiring and keeping good workers has
always been a challenge
for decades and i understand the
magnitude of today's
crisis in child care
directors absolutely want to keep their
doors open they want to serve working
families
noble reasons indeed and ones that we
should be able to fulfill
in a healthy well-funded truly equitable
child care
delivery system
but unfortunately that's not what we
have in our country and that's why i'm
opposing this bill
we all know that our child care system
has been broken for a long time
parents pay too much
and the federal government and other
entities not enough
child care workers mostly women have
been subsidizing the real cost of care
for for decades
and not only do we have a broken
system but we now have kids coming to us
with far greater needs than ever before
kids are growing up in a highly complex
fast-paced confusing world
like we've never seen and they bring
their reactions to it to child care
and the la
and the least we can do for our staff
who care for them often five days a week
all day long is to give them the tools
that they need to deal with these really
tough challenges
and the most and one of the most
effective tool is education and training
particularly in
child development
so when you take away early childhood
training
or the training requirements upon hire
you take away the most fundamental tool
in that toolbox for that teacher's
success to me it just doesn't make sense
to take this important tool away
and also there's some risk
with this
with this bill
because we can't forget that associate
teachers are
allowed to be alone with children based
on the licensing standards the ages of
children and the numbers of them
um
so
um and they also was so wait a minute so
so also an associate associate teacher
can be left alone for the first and last
half hour of each day
so
that can be a long 30 minutes when the
toddler
just pooped in their pants and two
preschoolers are fighting
but they don't but they could be there
with no training at all
and not only
and not until 90 days from higher is an
associate teacher required to get basic
health and safety training
no training involved so eventually
they'll get training but in the
beginning when they first come in it's
pretty risky for them and for the
children in their care
so some of the solutions
um
and i'm just speaking as a retired
person so i'm sort of out of out of the
the loop but what i do knows is that
there are many excellent groups working
on behalf of children in new hampshire
the unh preschool
development grant being one of them
and
the programs that can work with
licensing as mary jane walner mentioned
on waivers to get people in the door
provided there's a plan
to get them credits
that's already being done the council
for thriving
children
is working on supporting res supporting
training with resources and other
supports
so we have a lot of highly qualified
people in the field in new hampshire
working on behalf of of supporting
supporting providers this problem is not
new it's not going to go away
and i just encourage um everybody to try
to continue working
working together on this issue
caring for children is hard work kids
come to care with an array of unmet
needs and caregivers are given the task
of meeting those needs day after day
for this reason alone never before has
it been as important as it is now to
support our caregivers with quality
education and training so that they have
the tools that they need to be
successful in their work with young
children
i urge you
to do the right thing and support
children and their caregivers by
opposing this bill
thank you madam chair
thank you
will you take some questions oh yes i
will
thank you
um miss jewel do you have an idea of the
number of um
day care centers that are closing
because of our inability to
find
employees for them
i don't know an exact number but i do
know it's
rising
and i do feel having been in the field
for almost 50 years
that at some point
we have to face the fact that we do have
a broken system
and centers are going to close
follow-up please
how do you resolution solve that problem
well the solutions i'm sorry could you
repeat your question yeah you
recommended some solutions to the to the
issue of day care and i wanted to know
how those
resolve the problem the immediate
problem of funding day care because this
is a immediate problem for new hampshire
families right
i think working with
licensing is an immediate
problem i think working with
the council for thriving
children
for just offering some supports can be
an immediate problem it's a short-term
fix
i quite frankly think
that we still have to work on
on on getting
the whole system
fixed in child care we can't keep
putting band-aids on it
we've been doing that for 50 years
and it keeps getting harder
so i think at some point
and whether it takes centers
closing or closing classrooms because
there are no teachers
to get more people involved with this
crisis it's a huge crisis
i have no further questions thank you
representative
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
dr jewell for taking my question i'm
going to piggyback on what
representative grota was talking about
because i think
you and i agree philosophically
and i admire the what you you've said
about how we can best
care for children who are in poverty
that comprises a portion of my district
so thank you
philosophically i'm with you and here's
my question
to get out of a different angle of what
representative grota was asking you know
for for this
amendment it would only affect as i
understand it correct me if i'm wrong um
the entry level
workers who currently would be required
to take
some coursework at the higher education
level or post
secondary level
to work in a child care center
so
for the entry-level position that this
would affect
couldn't they gain that same
um level of understanding and continuing
education credits are not
excluded they would still be required
with this amendment
to since we have what you said maybe it
would be a good thing to shut down some
some child care centers i i look at it
from my constituents point of view that
you know a lot of folks face the crisis
of losing their child care and having no
options
and giving a pathway
you know i could see as a career
position to someone who's called to this
type of work wouldn't this enable
folks who haven't yet
achieved any post-secondary education to
choose
child care work as a career path that
otherwise wouldn't be available to them
since that's all
this amendment would affect as those
entry-level folks
says that make sense
yeah i guess but i i don't unders
i
first of all this yes this is an entry
level position for an associate teacher
which is one down from a lead teacher
so and again stressing that an associate
teacher is allowed to be alone with
children
so
i think that's an important piece
um
i
i agree with what you're saying
especially because they can get on or
they do they are required to receive 18
credit 18 hours of
training
a year ongoing once they're hired so
they will get training
so
but why can't they come in the door and
get with a weight waiver from licensing
that says as long as there's a plan in
place
to get nine credits
in
early childhood development or something
to do with child care
okay madam chair i think i have a
question then for the amendment authors
if that's okay
relevant to
the same
okay representative
williams or walnut would you care to
answer this question
so i can
i have to hear it first
so i i hear dr jewell's um
concern about unsupervised
um care
um
is i thought that
at least for this
um
entry level
to ch the way the amendment is written i
thought that correct me if i'm wrong
they would be under supervision
constantly and not allowed to be alone
with the kids
what how is
how should i interpret the amendment the
way it's written
no the amendment the amendment
addresses the qualifications to be an
associate teacher
and the first part of the admit and the
first
part of it is that you have to have a
thousand hours of super revised child
care experience
so someone who is working
um now in a child care center they don't
have the nine credits
but they would work and gain the
thousand hours under the supervision of
a lead teacher probably
and they would also have to have 30
hours of training
in child growth and development
um
the latter of which at least in the
amendment it could be some documented
life experience for instance
if someone had been a family child care
provider in their own home
and provided
care for children in their own home
that might be a very relevant life
experience
um
[Music]
so then after they had completed after
after they had completed the thousand
hours of supervised
they would then be able to be an
associate teacher and yes they could be
alone
with a class of children they would
still have to meet the child care
ratios
so if let's say it was um two-year
a group of two-year-olds there would be
one adult for every five to six children
um so as an associate teacher she or he
might be there with five or six children
for
you know maybe maybe the entire day
maybe just early in the morning when
staffing is
there are fewer children and you need
staff to cover maybe later in the
afternoon
but this does give you the flexibility
of having people
um
come in get work for the thousand hours
get the 30 hours have the 30 hours of
child growth and development training
and then be able to be an associate
teacher
that is very helpful thank you
there are other questions from it ms
jewell
seeing none thank you for your testimony
welcome
i'm sorry madam chair i i'm i tried to
raise my hand and i don't think you
caught me
um and i guess mr rules has left no i'm
still here yes representative
ask you may ask another question thank
you so hearing what um representative
walner said in clarifying
the um
the amendment
have you
do you feel less lenient in your
position or more lenient
well thank you for that question i i
understand it's my understanding
that that that 30 hours could
is could be interpreted
any way that you want
yes it could be as a child as a family
child care provider but it could be
um
no i mean i don't mean this in a
derogatory way in by any
means but it could be
raising raising children at home
that's my understanding how the language
is
and i think in
you know so it's open we have to my
that's my understanding honestly it's an
open interpretation
but the thousand hours is specified it's
my understanding that it is
under supervised
in the license
child care setting supervised care so
that turns out to be about six months of
roughly full-time
um
work in a child care program
thank you
my questions
okay then i called emily johnson
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee thank you for hearing my
testimony today
i am the state manager for save the
children action network and i have the
honor to represent over 3 000
uh supporters and volunteers across the
granite state
um at say the children action network we
believe all children deserve access to
high quality early childhood education
since 2014 we have worked in partnership
with community volunteers policy
advocates and state legislators to
improve accessibility and quality of new
hampshire's child care and early
learning programs
while well intentioned we do believe the
amendment to senate bill 133 would be a
step backward in our mission to provide
equitable access to high quality early
childhood education to all granite
staters which is why i am testifying in
opposition to this amendment
early childhood educators are
responsible for
the care and education of our youngest
citizens during some of the most
consequential years in their lives
while they provide essential service to
working families and help shape the
leaders of tomorrow
they are a routinely undervalued
workforce
senate bill 133
the amendment seeks to answer this
shameful undervaluing of teachers by
lowering the bar for higher education
required of child care employees
early childhood educators that i have
worked closely with in my role
understand that their jobs are
increasingly difficult as our state
copes with multiple crises impacting
children including the opioid epidemic
and the cova 19 pandemic
more children are coming into their care
with adverse childhood experiences
associated with the aforementioned
crises
child care providers should be supported
by the state with more resources and
trainings to help them provide high
quality care i think answering these
crises by diminishing teacher education
requirements would be a grave mistake
that could negatively impact generations
of granite staters
even setting our public health crises
aside the quality of care of our
children is a direct reflection of the
competence of the early childhood
educator and we should not consider
compromising the health and safety of
our children under any circumstances
so in conclusion i urge members of this
committee not to support this amendment
to senate bill 133 and i am happy to
take any questions you may have
thank you representative
thank you madam chair thank you for the
work that you
missed
um and i think philosophically you and i
agree i think what's difficult tell me
if i'm wrong
aren't
don't we have such a crisis in getting
enough caregivers
and isn't this a very narrow
um way to help us get folks that do have
applicable experience in the door
without needing post-secondary education
but
i mean don't you think this would be
since it's so narrow it's not addressing
continuing education credits it's not
addressing the other levels of child
care providers wouldn't this be a great
career path say for
a person who has had many kids or is an
immigrant who's been
is eager to get
um in this field couldn't this be seen
as a career path
of entry
for folks who don't fit the mold
currently
thanks for the question um
i think when we talk about child care
and
early childhood education
my belief and the
mission of my organization is to promote
equitable access to
the highest quality of care
and i just think that
any kind of diminishing of those
standards of care
just having a teacher there
and child care available for families
who may need it um
doesn't
isn't necessarily a huge help to
families when that care isn't high
quality and isn't setting that child up
for for success
thank you
are there any other questions from miss
johnson
representative roda
thank you
miss johnson um if your mission is to
provide the highest quality of care
available
how do we do that in a state like new
hampshire
i meet your mission statement how does
that because those are
that is a
i would think that is a sliding scale
correct
yeah i would i mean i would echo some of
my um
you know
karen jewell who
testified previously that
we do have a broken system
but that
i know from my work that there's no
shortage of organizations and
individuals on the ground who care
deeply about this issue
and so while i don't have a fully baked
solution to offer you today i think
you know many of the organizations
referenced earlier who are working on
behalf of kids
are working towards better solutions to
the very real crises
that we're facing i just don't believe
that this amendment uh
is the solution and i just want to add i
think
you know when we talk about teacher
shortages at other levels of education
this isn't a solution that's
routinely offered and so i
frankly don't understand why this would
be a solution
other than if we're considering early
childhood education in some way
less
important than other levels of education
which i of course don't believe it is i
think
these are teachers who are caring for
children during the most formative years
of their lives when the most brain
development is happening at the most
rapid pace throughout their lifetime so
i think
these teachers should be well trained
and taking a step backward in that
regard isn't
something we should consider
thank you representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so
we hear that the situation's in crisis
it's a broken it's banning after
band-aid and so forth
when we when will we see the results
you're talking about from all the
efforts you're describing to try to
address the situation when we're going
to see those
bear fruit
um
i'm i'm not sure i have an answer for
you i know
you know there are many different
grants and programs underway
i don't i think this is a
something that we do need to
apply more focus and resources to
address
the broken system as i see it
i'm not sure i have an answer for when
all the issues will be fixed but i i do
hope that we can continue to work on
this
thank you i don't envy your cask
questions
all right thank you very much for your
testimony ms johnson
thank you all anyone else who wishes to
testify
on this amendment if so please raise
your hand assistant
i'm sorry about that i was kicked out um
you were promoted so you could speak
please introduce yourself and talk to us
certainly um hello thank you for letting
me speak my name is marion barter i'm
the executive director at merrimack
valley daycare service and blueberry
express day care um in the concord area
i don't think i i'd like to
say that i support this bill
or this amendment i don't think it's
ideal i don't think anyone thinks the
idea of changing qualifications for
teachers is ideal but the reality is
that we cannot hire and when we can't
hire class when we can't hire staff to
work in our classrooms
we can't serve the families that are
calling us up and begging for spaces and
as much as i appreciate karen and
emily's view that you know this will
diminish the field and it's better
you know it's better to close child care
facilities i i can't fathom what good
could come of that
my agency works primarily with
low-income families so our mission is to
care for children at risk of abuse and
neglect low-income families and children
with special needs and right now my wait
list is long enough to open up a whole
nother child care facility and if i
could hire i could take these children
and the reality of the situation of the
children that i care for is that if i do
not offer them a space in my licensed
facility where they are supervised by
myself by a team of teachers and by
child care licensing it's going to be
the next door neighbor or mom's
boyfriend or someone they met on
craigslist who will be caring for these
children and that's devastating and for
the first time in our 50-year
career our agency has been around since
1968 and for the very first time i find
myself in a situation where i am
waitlisting children who are in the dcyf
system you know i'm wait listing foster
children and i
i just find that an incredible shame and
really
what this
what this amendment will do is give me
just a slim chance that i may be able to
hire some people and i may be able to
help some of those families it's not
ideal no one thinks it's ideal and
honestly if
someone would want to consider it for a
sundowning that i i think that we would
encourage that too because there are a
lot of
innovations that are starting to come
out to bring people to the field but it
will take a couple years for that to
happen and i'm not sure how many of us
will still be standing in a couple years
so
thank you very much for letting me
testify and
i think i'll take any questions take a
question
certainly
thank you
miss barter for testifying
we hear we've heard this is my second
term so it's not as if i've heard this
forever but this has been going this is
an ongoing problem in new hampshire
and your um statement that things you
know are going to change
in a positive direction
is great to hear
and whatever we can do
i i will support whatever we can do to
get us there how can we find out learn
more about
these
proposals
or these uh you know these
recommendations so that
as a committee we learn more about this
because i think it's an important
point for the future of young families
and growing families and the children of
new hampshire which is what we're trying
to attract
certainly um i'm vice chair of the child
care advisory council the new hampshire
child care advisory council and i think
that the executive council would be
pleased to gather the information about
the different initiatives that are
happening statewide and pre and present
them to a committee if you would like us
to
please okay
certainly
are there other questions from
all maybe thank you very much mr parker
thank you
melissa clement
good afternoon madam chair and members
of the committee um for the record my
name is melissa clement and i am the
chief of child care licensing unit in
the department of health and human
services i appreciate the opportunity to
speak and wish to express that the
department recognizes the difficulties
child care providers are facing in
hiring staff
the department has provided relief to
the staffing crisis by implementing an
expedited waiver process as of november
23 2020 to allow assistant teachers to
work as associate teachers throughout
the state of emergency
on november 24th we approved 56 requests
received on that first day
as of april 23rd the department has
approved 225 requests from child care
providers so that 502 assistant teachers
can work as associate teachers
currently the child care provider can
hire someone who does not meet the
requirements in rule to work as an
associate teacher during this state of
emergency
we respectfully request that the staff
qualifications remain in rulemaking and
therefore we are testifying in
opposition to this amendment we are on
schedule to submit revised rules to the
joint legislative committee on
administrative rules also known as jail
card in this september
the revisions have been informed by the
testimony the department has heard in
regards to hb 230 as well as feedback we
received over four zoom meetings with
providers since october of 2020 the most
recent meeting held earlier this month
in addition to staff qualifications
providers and the department identified
other changes were needed therefore we
will be putting forth a comprehensive
revision to our existing rules we
anticipate that the draft rule will be
sent to providers in may to receive
additional input prior to engaging in
the formal rulemaking process
we also heard in the testimony to hb 230
that there are providers who are
concerned about reducing educational
requirements much like you've heard
today
and we are working on balancing both
perspectives and the revised rules to
accomplish flexibility and quality the
rulemaking process which includes the
public hearing and the hearing before
gel car provides additional feedback
from the providers to the department on
both perspectives
should the state of emergency end prior
to the revised rules going in front of
jail car we are committed to continuing
this waiver process and are actively
working with our legal counsel on how to
accomplish allowing the existing waivers
to for assistant teachers to remain in
effect until the revised rules are in
place
we encourage programs to continue to
reach out for waivers and we are
committed to working with them to
provide a safe environment for children
with respect to the specific amendment
section 1 lines 9-10 includes the
provision to allow documented life
experience to be substituted for 30
hours of training in child growth and
development should the committee decide
to approve the amendment the department
respectively requests that the committee
put forth a definition of life
experience that would be an equivalent
to 30 hours of training in child growth
and development
in accordance with professional
standards the domains of child growth
and development include the
developmental milestones from birth
through age eight years related to the
physical cognitive social and emotional
development of children
as currently written the department is
uncertain how we could equitably
regulate the provision without what is
also known as oral rulemaking where
we're deciding on a case-by-case basis
if someone's life experience is the
equivalent to 30 hours of child growth
and development training
and with that i
ask if you have any questions i'd be
happy to answer them thank you for
allowing me this time
thank you miss clement
the um
proposal that you're going to be
presenting to jail car
does it have any other
rules that have been discussed with this
committee does it include other
rules
yes it includes um a lot of the
testimony that we heard throughout hb
230 we are looking at that testimony and
seeing where our rules can be changed in
order to assist providers in providing
the care that they need to care that
they need to in order to have their
business
we recognize throughout that testimony
and throughout those additional meetings
that we've had with providers since
october that the rules in general just
needed to be looked at again to make
sure they were clear to make sure that
they could be
implemented by programs and to make sure
that we weren't unduly burdening
programs so we are
revising our rules based on looking at
all of those
concerns thank you miss miss clement
i believe that several members of the
committee would like to receive those
rules when you send them out for initial
comments so if you could do that i'd
appreciate it yes absolutely we'll send
them to the committee
thank you
representative
thank you madam chair um
miss clement can you tell me is this are
states getting federal money to address
this child care issue new new money for
that
i can speak
terms but i am not the agency that
receives those funds the funds come
through the
the bureau of child development head
start collaboration in the department of
health and human services through the
child development block grant
so they would they are receiving funds
and i know that money it has been
earmarked to address the staffing issue
however i can't really speak to the
specifics as to how much that is because
that isn't a different agency and i
don't want to put forth any numbers that
would not be accurate so can you just
tell me who it is again
yeah it's um the bureau of child
development and head start collaboration
in the department of health and human
services
thank you
for administering the child care
development block grant
are there any other questions
yes
thank you um
so i see that this
amends
rsa 170e 11 part 1
which
has various general areas of rule making
the department supposed to engage in my
question is
you don't have any place else in statute
related to
requirements for training for
being involved in child care
where there's uh in statute
particular requirements of number of
hours of experience or training or
anything like that
it is not under the child care statute
all of that information is contained in
our administrative rules um which is hec
so that is where all those specifics are
mentioned there's not there's not a
specific section in the statute
regarding the tr the number of hours of
training or the educational requirements
there is in the statute a voluntary
credentialing system which is
administered under the bureau of child
development and head start collaboration
but that is a voluntary
voluntary program and in statute it
references that the first level of any
credentialing system is the equivalent
to what is in the child care licensing
rule
thank you
lisa ranfos
okay please introduce your mutant
introduce yourself and then meet
yourself and then talk to us sorry about
that um for the record my name is lisa
rampas i am a resident of allens town in
hampshire i'm also the executive
director of the child study and
development center at the university of
new hampshire which is a lab school on
the campus of unh
um i had a prepared testimony but i know
that it's been a long day and i just
want to add to some of the comments that
have has already been said by some of my
colleagues
um being in the field for over 20 years
um i i think that
this is not a new issue i think it's uh
because we're in a pandemic and child
care is getting attention
that
we are seeing more than we have been in
the past
um but i do think in opposition to this
bill that the
the continuous um response of lowering
qualifications is unacceptable
as emily stated earlier we would never
do that to the department of education
teachers why do we continuously do it to
early childhood
um i have the privilege of working with
interns i teach two internship courses
here at the university and i see how
practical application makes an impact on
who one becomes as a teacher
i also can attest to the students who
come out of our program are gobbled up
by
other programs and unfortunately um
it it does have a bit to do about money
when you have good pay and benefits
you're going to get better staff and
unfortunately early childhood isn't
there yet however
it can't always be about the barriers so
what do we do about it and yes there are
programs in our state right now the
apprenticeship program the teach program
that are making strides
and yes it will take some time before
that happens
um i also have the privilege to sit on a
well-represented um
pretty new committee if you will looking
at alternative pathways because i
believe strongly that people need
education and training and how do we
provide that we have these gems called
lab schools in our states that many have
been closing let's look at how they can
provide training um or even types of
residency programs or apprenticeship
programs to allow people to get the
training and then go out into the field
instead of just saying okay let's give a
waiver and melissa clement that is not a
dig on you you are doing an outstanding
job so thank you for what you do every
single day
um
but we can't continue to just
minimize things how do we hold that high
standard because of the impact it has on
young children emily stated that well so
i don't need to to reiterate that
um things like you know module-based
learning where they have some coaching
and some pre-work and after work
um years ago in our state with the
quality dollars through the cdbg grant i
think i could be wrong there so please
don't quote me um we were able to access
education through wheelock college um
mary jane walnut you might be able to
speak to this perhaps but i was so
fortunate to be part of one of the
cohorts that went through that i would
not have had the opportunity to get a
master's program without that
couldn't afford it so it was grant
funded the teachers came to us it was
amazing
and the thing that i had going for it
was a cohort model so people were
learning together and i'm still in
contact with all of most of my cohort
members even today and we graduated you
know back in 20 2007
so all i'm trying to say is that there
are ways that we can provide
education and training if we just think
outside the box look at what works and
look at best practice thank you so much
for hearing me today and i'm hoping for
questions if anyone has any
representative seems to have a question
thank you
so these programs that are available in
new hampshire through all these
are they do they cost someone money do
you pay for them
so there are scholarship based programs
to the best of my knowledge and there
might be people on this call who could
speak better to that um but so for
example they get a scholarship to get
the training i believe that's all free
they get paid a wage in the teach
program they're working for another
program every time they meet a milestone
they get a bump and pay and so they're
getting education experience and more
money follow up
follow up
there seems to be
many advocates
for day care on this call
and they all recognize a problem
but i have yet to hear a solution
why is that that you may not be able to
answer that call but i i'd like the
people who have spoken to us
to answer that
thank you for the question or the
comment i think
it costs money quality costs money and
if we want to provide a system of early
childhood that meets the needs of all of
our children in new hampshire it's going
to cost money but yet the return on
investment has been proven over and over
and over
through many studies that have already
happened in in years past
if we provide the money up front there's
less crime there's less um special
education there's there's
less everything that costs money in the
long run if we just put it into early
childhood but it takes qualified people
to be able to work with those children
not just anyone understands child
development so when you know children
have temper tantrums or what's called
temper tantrums no we can't view it like
that all behavior
is a communication of some kind it's our
job to figure out what those children
are trying to say what they're
struggling with and provide them
strategies that will impact them
positively socially and emotionally to
be well productive citizens as they get
older
thank you are there any other questions
all right seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you so much is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
this amendment to senate bill 133
if so please raise your hand
senator schultz
you're not testifying you've been asking
questions
um thank you madam chair i was trying to
i never have quite the graceful way to
bring up a related issue so i just sent
to miriam to forward to all of us on
edna a report a study report from 2019
that
includes recommendations that
um that this amendment is similar to
and includes and it was a study
committee made up of two democrats and
two republicans in
in the house and senate total
um
and it is a review of barriers to the
child care business which is an
interesting angle to look at it and um i
think it would be helpful to the whole
committee so i'm just mentioning it now
that look for it from miriam
um this study
committee report is very short but very
informative on all of these topics that
we are curious about in child care thank
you this will be going to representative
scitec subcommittee
so we will be discussing it then
amendment
133 has already been parsed that's right
so is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
seeing none i am closing the hearing on
this amendment
i'm i'm done for the day so i hope the
rest of you will have a pleasant evening
thank you thank you
madam chair do you have any information
about upcoming um meetings